COOL GOOD MORNING WE ARE GOING
TO CALL THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET TO ORDER LET ME JUST
READ OFF A COUPLE OF-
LOGISTICAL ISSUES AGAIN THE
PANELISTS ON THE AGENDA ARE
APPEARING REMOTELY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY THERE WILL BE NO
VOTES IN COMMITTEE TODAY. WE
ARE ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT
THE MD HEARING BOTH IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND ON THE PHONE.
THE PHONE NUMBER IS
877-692-8957 PUBLIC ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO
OH TWO THEY SHOULD BE ON THE
SCREEN IF YOU'RE- WATCHING THIS
ON- ASSEMBLY TV. OR ONLINE. THE
ASSEMBLY GIVE ANY ISSUES PLEASE
CONTACT OUR ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE OFFICE AT. NINE ONE
SIX THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO.
NINE NINE WE ARE PRESENTING
SIXTEEN BILLS TODAY IN THE
COMMUNITY MISTER MIRACLE LIAM
IS JESSICA HOMES AND UPON THE
FINANCE WILL PRESENT ALL THESE
BILLS TOGETHER. MISTER BROOKS
ALLEN WITH THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION WILL ALSO SEPARATELY
PRESENT S. B. ONE SEVENTY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AFTERWARDS WE WILL BE- WILL
GIVE MISTER BRYAN BROWN WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE TIME TO MAKE ANY
COMMENTS IF YOU CHOOSE TO DO
SO. THEY WERE GONNA TAKE NUMBER
COMMENTS AND PUBLIC COMMENTS.
AGAIN THERE'S NO PHONE
COMMITTEES DALY JUST TURNED
OVER TO OUR VICE SHOULD RECEIVE
YOUR ROOM OPENING COMMENTS.
NOTICING COMMENTS LET'S START
WE WILL START. WITH U. S. B.
ONE FIFTY FIVE RESOURCES AND
WILL TURN OVERTURN THE CIRCLING.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING- CHAIR
TANG BY STRIP FONG IN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ERICA LEE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
PRESENT AS A STATE ON SIXTEEN
BUDGET BILLS- AND JUST FOR A
HIGH HIGHLIGHTS THESE BILLS
REPRESENT THREE PARTY
AGREEMENTS ON SIGNIFICANT
BUDGET PROPOSALS FOR WHICH
FUNDS ARE ALLOCATED IN THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET
ACT. AND FURTHER WORK WAS
NECESSARY TO PROGRAM DOLLARS-
AN EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF WORK
HAS GONE INTO CLOSING WHICH BUT
WHAT HAS BEEN- AN EXTRAORDINARY
BUDGET YEAR- STARTING WITH
PROJECTED RECORD DEFICITS AND
ENDING WITH A RECORD SURPLUS-
ALONG WITH ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
FUNDS- I WILL PRESENT
HIGHLIGHTS FROM EACH BELL- AS
WAS MENTIONED BACK TO BACK
JOINED BY MY COLLEAGUES AND AT
THE END WILL BE HAPPY TO
RESPOND. TO QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU I WILL
BEGIN WITH. AB S. B. ONE FIFTY
FIVE. THIS IS THE RESOURCES
TRAILER BILL THIS BILL MAKES
VARIOUS CHANGES RELATED TO
PUBLIC RESOURCES INCLUDING.
ESTABLISHING A TWO HUNDRED
MILLION ANNUAL CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION FROM THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
FOR WILDFIRE AND FOREST
RESILIENCE ACTIVITIES. FROM
TWENTY TWENTY THREE THROUGH
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
NINE- IT ESTABLISHES ANNUAL
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR
PROGRAMS RELATED TO WILDFIRE
AND FOREST RESILIENCE FUNDED IN
THE TWENTY AT TWENTY TWENTY AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET AX- IT
STREAMLINES. THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT
REQUIREMENTS FOR PROJECTS THAT
CONSERVE RESTORE PROTECT OR
ENHANCE FISH AND WILDLIFE AND
THEIR HABITATS. EXTENDS THE
WATER SHUTOFF MORATORIUM DATE
TO DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- IT INCLUDES A
CODIFIED LANGUAGE THAT
ESTABLISHES PARAMETERS FOR
VARIOUS PROGRAMS AND ACTIVITIES
THAT HAVE COMMITTED. A FUNDING
IN FUTURE YEARS INCLUDING BUT
NOT LIMITED TO MULTI BENEFIT
AND NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS
EXTREME HEATS. COASTAL
ADAPTATION AND PROTECTION AND
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE CENTERS.
AND IT EXTENDS A SUNSET OF THE
NET ENERGY METERING. FUEL CELL
PROGRAM BY TWO YEARS FROM
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. TO DECEMBER. THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE. I'M
NEXT MOVING ON TO AB ONE SIXTY
TWO WHICH IS OUR LABOR TRAILER
BILL THIS BILL ESTABLISHES THE
COMMUNITY ECONOMIC RESILIENCE
FUND PROGRAM AND APPROPRIATE
SIX HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME
ARE BY FEDERAL FUNDS TO THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT. FOR IMPLEMENTATION-
I'M- A COMMUNITY ECONOMIC
RESILIENCE FUND ALSO KNOWN AS
SURF IS DESIGNED TO BUILD AND
THE BALL AND SUSTAINABLE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY FROM THE
IMPACTS OF KOBE NINETEEN. ON
CALIFORNIA'S INDUSTRIES WORKERS
AND COMMUNITIES AND TO SUPPORT
THE STATE'S RECOVERY THE BILL
INCLUDES INVESTMENTS FAR
PLANNING GRANTS AS WELL AS
COMPETITIVE IMPLEMENTATION
GRANTS AWARDED BY THE STATE TO
REGIONAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS. ON A ROLLING BASIS AS
HIGH ROAD TRANSITION PLANNING
EFFORTS RESULT IN CLEAR
STRATEGIES TO SPUR GROWTH IN
HIGH RISK INDUSTRIES. MOVING ON
TO THE NEXT BILL AB SB ONE
SIXTY THREE WHICH IS THE
GENERAL GOVERNMENT TRAILER
BILL. THIS BILL EXPANDS ON
ACTIONS PREVIOUSLY TAKEN BY THE
LEGISLATURE AS IT RELATES TO
THE MEMBER'S FOR CART GRAMS AND
THIRD PARTY PROVIDERS- SUCH AS
REQUIRING THE GAMBLING CONTROL
COMMISSION. TO REFUND ANY
ANNUAL FEES ALREADY PAID FOR A
STATE GAMBLING LICENSE BUT
WERE- DO BETWEEN JANUARY THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO JULY
SIXTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE-
AND TO REFUND ANY ANNUAL FEES
ALREADY PAID BY A THIRD PARTY
PROVIDER PROPOSITIONS THEIR
SERVICES THAT WERE DUE BETWEEN
SEPTEMBER FIRST OF. TWENTY
TWENTY TWO JULY SIXTEENTH OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- THIS BILL
ALSO CLARIFIES THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY SHALL
COORDINATE WITH AGENCIES AND
STATE ENTITIES TO IDENTIFY
EXISTING STATE CONTRACTS WHICH
COULD BE REPLACED WITH
CENTRALIZED CONTRACTS FOR
SHARED SERVICES- AND LASTLY
THIS BILL ALSO AMENDS THE
STATUTE TO INCREASE BY
SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLARS THE
AMOUNT APPROPRIATED FOR
TRANSFER FROM THE STATE PROJECT
INFRASTRUCTURE BOND. TO THE
OPERATING FUNDS OF THE ASSEMBLY
AND SENATE FOR MODIFICATIONS TO
THE WEST WING RELATED TO THE
ANNEX PROJECTS. MOVING ON TO AB
AS THE ONE SIXTY FIVE- THIS IS
THE BARGAINING UNIT SEVEN AND
EIGHT SIDE LETTERS. HELLO BILL
THIS BILL RATIFIES SIGNED
LETTERS BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION ALSO
KNOWN AS CSL THE EIGHT. AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION
FIREFIGHTERS CAL BY OUR LOCAL
TWO EIGHT EIGHT ONE. THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL DO NOT
TAKE EFFECT UNLESS FUNDS ARE
APPROPRIATED BY THE LEGISLATURE.
I'M MOVING O TO AB S. B. ONE
SIXTY SIX WHICH IS THE CANNABIS
TRAILER BILL. THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET INCLUDES THIRTY
MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS CONTROL
TO ADMINISTER EIGHTY WEAVER AND
FOR ALL PROGRAM. CONTINGENT
UPON FUTURE LEGISLATION THIS
BILL ESTABLISHES THE PARAMETERS
FOR THAT PROGRAM. SPECIFICALLY
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS CONTROL TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT A FEE WAIVER PROGRAM
BY JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. AND A BILL OF THE
FEET OF FOR A PROGRAM BY
JANUARY FIRST TWO TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. THE BILL ALSO
ESTABLISHES OF THE DEFINITION
OF EQUITY APPLICANTS AND
LICENSEES FOR THE PURPOSES OF
THIS PROGRAM AND APPROPRIATES
TEN THOUSAND GENERAL FUND TO
THE DEPARTMENT TO HELP.
IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM. ABOUT
MOVING ONTO AB . B. ONE SIXTY
SEVEN THE K. THROUGH TWELVE
TRAILER BILL. THIS BILL
CLARIFIES THAT LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES CAN'T EARN
APPORTIONMENT FUNDING FOR
STUDENTS PARTICIPATING IN
INDEPENDENT STUDY BECAUSE OF
KOBE NINETEEN RELATED
QUARANTINE. BEGINNING DAY ONE
OF THE FORTY. EIGHT CLARIFIES
THAT FOR THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO SCHOOL YEAR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES MAY OBTAIN
SIGNED INDEPENDENT STUDY MASTER
AGREEMENTS UP TO THIRTY DAYS.
AFTER STUDENT BEGINS AN
INDEPENDENT STUDY PROGRAM.
EXTENDS THE AMOUNT OF TIME A
SUBSTITUTE TEACHER CAN PROVIDE
INSTRUCTION. AND A CLASS FROM
THIRTY TO SIXTY DAYS. AND IT
MAKES VERY TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS INCLUDING
UPDATES TO FEDERAL OF WORKSHOPS.
THE NEXT TRAILER BILL IS AB SB
ONE SIXTY EIGHT CHILD CARE ON
THIS BILL TEMPORARILY
AUTHORIZES REIMBURSEMENT BASED
ON ENROLLMENT RATHER THAN
ATTENDANCE. AND UP TO SIXTEEN
ADDITIONAL PAID NON OPERATIONAL
DAYS FOR EMERGENCY CHILD CARE
BRIDGE PROVIDERS. ARE THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
FUNDED AND AUTHORIZED THESE
TYPES OF ASSISTANCE FOR OTHER
CHILD CARE PROGRAMS I'M AT THE
BRIDGE PROGRAM WAS
UNINTENTIONALLY EXCLUDED THIS
BILL ADDRESSES THAT ISSUE- AB
ONE SIXTY NINE IS AB SB ONE
SIXTY NINE IS POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION TRAILER BILL. AND
THIS BILL ESTABLISHES THE
HIGHER EDUCATION STUDENT
HOUSING GRANT PROGRAMS PROVIDE
ONE TIME GRANTS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY AND
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
TO CONSTRUCT STUDENT HOUSING OR
TO ACQUIRE AND RENOVATE
COMMERCIAL PROPERTIES INTO
STUDENT HOUSING FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS. IT IS ALICE IS THE
HIGHER EDUCATION CAPACITY
EXPANSION THAT PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE ONE TIME GRANTS FOR
CAPACITY EXPANSION PROJECTS. TO
SUPPORT INCREASED CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT INVOLVEMENT AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
AND IMPLEMENTS REYES CHANGES TO
IMPROVE FINANCIAL AID AND
COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY. LIVING
ON TO AB SB ONE SEVENTY ONE THE
HEALTH TRAILER BILL THIS BILL
CODIFIES THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE HOME AND COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES ARE H. C. B. S.
SPENDING PLAN AS APPROVED BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IT
PROVIDES A ONE YEAR EXTENSION
OF TIME AND DISTANCE OF
STANDARDS FOR MEDIC CAL MANAGED
CARE SERVICES. IT REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO CONDUCT AN
EVALUATION SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATION TO DETERMINE
WHETHER A HOUSING SUPPORT
SERVICE BENEFIT MAY BE
SUPPORTED IN THE FUTURE AND
LASTLY APPROPRIATE SIX POINT
FOUR MILLION AND FEDERAL GRANT
FUNDING FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS
RESOURCES IMPACTED BY KOBE
NINETEEN. MOVING ON TO US THE
AB ONE SEVENTY TWO WHICH IS THE
HUMAN SERVICES TRAILER BILL.
THIS BILL CREATES A CENTER FOR
DATA INSIGHTS AND INNOVATION
WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY IT
CODIFIES THE COMMUNITY CARE
EXPANSION AND CAREER PATHWAYS
PROGRAMS. CLARIFIES FIND
MATCHING REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
GUARANTEED INCOME PILOT
PROGRAM. AND AUTHORIZES DATA
SHARING BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES AND
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION FOR
CHILDREN'S FOOD BENEFITS- AND
ADDITIONALLY MAKES OTHER
TECHNICAL AND CONFORMING
CHANGES. AND MOVING TO AB S. B.
ONE SEVENTY THREE PUBLIC SAFETY
TRAILER BILL- THIS BILL
PROHIBITS THE BRINGING OR
POSSESSION OF A LOADED FIREARM
OR OTHER SPECIFIED WEAPON TO
THE STATE OFFICE BUILDING
LOCATED AT TEN TWENTY ONE-
STREET IN SACRAMENTO. THIS
PROHIBITION ALREADY EXIST FOR
THE STATE CAPITOL IN
LEGISLATIVE OFFICES. THIS
LANGUAGE ENSURES THAT THE SAME
RESTRICTIONS REGARDING FIREARMS
AND OTHER DEADLY WEAPONS- AS
OTHER BUILDINGS OCCUPIED BY THE
LEGISLATURE APPLY IN THE NEW
BUILDING. AND IT MOVING TO AB
SB ONE SEVENTY FOR THE
TRANSPORTATION TRAILER BILL.
THIS ABOUT BILL A LOT OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
CONTINUE IMPLEMENTING
EFFICIENCY MEASURES TO MAKE ITS
PROCESSES MORE EFFICIENT AND
REDUCE THE NEED FOR IN PERSON
OFFICE VISITS. IT ALSO CHANGES
CONFORMING STATE LAW TO FEDERAL
LAW REGARDING- MOTOR CARRIERS.
MOVING ON TO AB S. B. ONE
SEVENTY FIVE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS- THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACTS INCLUDED A TEN
BILLION DOLLAR. HOUSING PACKAGE
TO PROMOTE AND MAINTAIN STABLE
HOUSING FOR ADDITIONAL AND
EXPANDED RENTAL ASSISTANCE
FORECLOSURE PREVENTION.
MORTGAGE ASSISTANCE AND FIRT
TIME HOME ON OUR INVESTMENTS
THE BUDGET ALSO INCLUDED A
STORY HOMELESSNESS PACKAGE OF.
ELEVEN POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS OVER TWO YEARS. AB SB
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN MAKES
AMENDMENTS TO HOUSING
PROVISIONS CLARIFYING THE
INTENT AND CORRECTING DRAFTING
ERRORS OF OUR LANGUAGE IN
ADDITION AB SB ONE SEVENTY FIVE
INCLUDES AUTHORITY TO PROVIDE
EMERGENCY HOMELESS SHELTER AND
SERVICES. AT CAL EXPO. AND
LASTLY. THIRTY MILLION ONE TIME
LABOR AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
FUNDS BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS STRATEGIC
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS FOCUSED ON
THE CONSTRUCTION ALTERATION AND
REPAIR PROJECTS AS REQUIRED IN
SB ONE FORTY. AGIT MOVING TO AB
SB ONE SEVENTY SIX WHICH IS A
SMALL BUSINESS TRAILER BILL
THIS BILL MAKES TECHNICAL IN
CLARIFYING CHANGES TO VARIOUS
GRANT PROGRAMS ADMINISTERED BY
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OR GO BEST.
INCLUDING THE SMALL BUSINESS
COBIT NINETEEN RELIEF GRANT
PROGRAM THE CALIFORNIA MICRO
BUSINESSES COVER NINETEEN
REALLY GRANT PROGRAMS AND THE
CALIFORNIA VENUES GRANT
PROGRAM. THE BILL ALSO MAKES
TECHNICAL FIXES TO THE HOMELESS
HIRING CREDIT THE NEW STUDIO
CONSTRUCTION FROM CREDIT THE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS TO
PROGRAM AND THE PROGRAM ADOPTED
AS PART OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACT. THAT CHANGES HOW
SALES TAX ON USED VEHICLES ARE
COLLECTED. AND LAST- AB S. B.
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN PUBLIC SAFETY
RELATED TO PARKS. THIS BILL
CODIFIES THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER WHICH PROVIDES
A JUDICIAL BRANCH THE NECESSARY
AUTHORITY TO CONTINUE OFFERING
REMOTE. CIVIL PROCEEDINGS UNTIL
JANUARY THIRTY FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO- THIS BILL ALSO
REQUIRES A JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO
SUBMIT A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR ON
THE USE OF REMOTE TECHNOLOGY IN
CIVIL ACTION BY. THE TRIAL
COURT'S INCLUSIVE OF COUNTY
SPECIFIC DATA. BY JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY THREE- AND AS
PART OF- THE ACCESS TO JUSTICE
PACKAGE THIS BILL ALSO
INCREASES OF USE FOR
TRANSCRIPTS PREPARED BY. A
COURT REPORTER THE BILL ALSO
ELIMINATES VARIOUS TYPES OF
CRIMINAL ADMINISTRATIVE FEES
CHARGED BY LOCAL GOVERNMENT FOR
INDIVIDUALS. WHO ARE ARRESTED
PROSECUTED OR CONVICTED OF A
CRIME- THIS BILL MAKES THE
UNPAID BALANCE OF MANY COURT
PUT IMPOSE COSTS FOR THESE P.
TYPES AND IMPOSSIBLE AND
COLLECT UNCOLLECTIBLE. IN SHORT
I DEBT INCURRED IN THE PAST FOR
THESE FEES CAN NO LONGER BE
COLLECTED. AND THIS BILL
ELIMINATES THE ADMINISTRATIVE
FEES FOR FELONY OR MISDEMEANOR
DIVERSION RESTITUTION
COLLECTION AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TESTING- I'M AND I APOLOGIZE I.
I SKIPPED OVER OUR BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR WHICH IS AB S. B. ONE
SEVENTY I'M SORRY GO BACK TO
THAT AND THEN I BELIEVE I WILL
BE JOINED BY. MY COLLEAGUE
JESSICA HOLMES- AB ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT AB S. B. ONE SEVENTY AS
THE B. B. J. THAT AMENDS THE
TWENTY FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET ACT- THIS
BILL INCLUDES PROGRAM DETAILS
FOR APPROXIMATELY. MINUTES
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS IN INVESTMENTS.
OVER MULTIPLE YEARS TO ADDRESS
AND REDUCE THE STATE'S
MULTIFACETED CLIMATE RISKS
RANGING FROM WATER RESILIENCE
WILDFIRES HEAT. AND SEA LEVEL
RISE AND SUPPORT FOR NATURAL
RESOURCES BUILDING. INCLUDING
FISH AND WILDLIFE HABITAT AND
PARKS. IS INVESTMENTS ARE IN
ADDITION TO THE APPROXIMATELY
SEVEN POINT FOUR BILLION OVER
FOUR YEARS THAT WAS ALREADY
PROGRAM IN THE BUDGET FOR A
TOTAL INVESTMENT OF
APPROXIMATELY SIXTEEN BILLION
ACROSS. VARIOUS CLIMATE
INVESTMENT PRIORITIES- IS
SPECIFICALLY I WANT TO POINT
OUT THE BUDGETS WILDFIRE WATER
AND CLIMATE RESILIENCE
INVESTMENTS- ENABLE THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED IN EARLY
ACTION PACKAGE TOTALING FIVE
HUNDRED THIRTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A BROAD SET OF
INVESTMENTS THAT SUPPORT OF.
STATEWIDE STRATEGY FOCUSED ON
FOREST HEALTH AND FIRE
PREVENTION. THIS BILL INCLUDES
AN ADDITIONAL NINE HUNDRED
EIGHTY EIGHT MILLION IN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. OF AN
ADDITIONAL WILDFIRE AND FOREST
RESILIENCE INVESTMENTS THIS
REPRESENTS A NE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT TO
SUPPORT WILDFIRE AND FOREST
RESILIENCE WHICH REPRESENT THE
LARGEST INVESTMENT AND- STATE
HISTORY FOR THESE ACTIVITIES.
THE BUDGET ALSO AND SUCH CHAIN
THAT AS- A TO HUNDRED MILE
ANNUAL. APPROPRIATE FROM
GREENHOUSE OR FUND FOR LIKE
WILDFIRE AND FOREST RESILIENCE
TO BODIES FROM TWENTY TWENTY.
TO TWENTY THREE THREE TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY NINE- ADDITIONALLY
THIS BILL BRINGS THE TOTAL
WATER IN DROUGHT RESILIENCE
PACKAGE TO FIVE POINT TWO
MILLION OVER THREE YEARS TO
PROVIDE IMMEDIATE DROUGHT
RELIEF. ACROSS SUPPORT AND
ADDRESS LONG TERM WATER
RESILIENCE AND THIS BILL
INCLUDES THREE POINT SEVEN
BILLION GENERAL FUND OVER THREE
YEARS TO SUPPORT INVESTMENTS
THAT ADDRESS THE STATE'S MULTI
FACETED- CLIMATE RISK.
INVESTING INVEST AVAILABLE
CLIMATE SCIENCE TO INFORM
DECISIONS. MOVING ON THIS BB
DAY ALSO INCLUDES- IT SUPPORTS
CASH FLOW LOANS TO QUALIFIED
DISTRICT HOSPITALS TO ADDRESS
FINANCIAL IMPACTS OF THE KOBE
NINETEEN PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. IT PROVIDES
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY FOR THREE
KOBE NINETEEN RELATED FEDERAL
GRANTS TO SUPPORT STATE IN
PERSON SCHOOL INSTRUCTION IN
THE AMOUNT OF EIGHT HUNDRED
AND- EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION.
EXPENSE TESTING CAPACITY
DETECTION AND CONTAINMENT AND
THE AMOUNT OF FIVE HUNDRED
THREE MILLION. AND IMPROVE
RESPONSE TO HIGH RISK AND UNDER
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS AND THE
AMOUNT OF NINETEEN POINT THREE
MILLION. THIS BILL ALSO
TEMPORARILY. ELIGIBILITY FOR
STATE FUNDED CASH ASSISTANCE
AND OTHER SERVICES TO AFGHAN
RIVALS IN ELIGIBLE FOR
FEDERALLY FUNDED BENEFITS- IT
PROVIDES AN ADDITIONAL ELEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION TO THE STATE
PROJECT INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING
FOR DESIGN AND PRE CONSTRUCTION
ACTIVITIES RELATED TO THE
VISITOR CENTER A COMPONENT OF
THE STATE CAPITOL ANNEX
PROJECTS AND FOR ENHANCED
SECURITY UPGRADES- AND- LASTLY.
AS PART OF THE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE PACKAGE THIS BUDGET
INCLUDES THIRTY MILLION FOR
COURTS TO COVER THE EMPLOYMENT
COST IN QUARTERS. AND TO
INCREASE LANGUAGE ACCESS AND
THIRTY MILLION TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF COURT REPORTERS. AND
FAMILY AND CIVIL LAW CASES- I
WILL NOT TURN- THE LORD TO
JESSICA HOMES TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION- IN
REGARDS TO A PROPOSAL FOR THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ERICA AND
JESSICA HOLMES AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- WE
UNDERSTOOD THAT THE COMMITTEE-
WOULD LIKE A PRESENTATION ON-
AND IT THAT PROPOSAL THAT WE
HAVE IN SB ONE SIXTY SEVEN TO
INCREASE RESOURCES FOR THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION- I'M
GOING TO HAVE MY COLLEAGUE
BROOKS ALLEN PROVIDE A LITTLE
CONTEXT- IN BACKGROUND AND THEN
I WILL BE- PRESENTING. AT THE
REQUEST SO- ALTERNATE ALTERNATE
OVER TO BROOKE'S. I THANK YOU
JESSICA. GOOD MORNING SIR CAME
BY STEHR FONG MEMBERS HI MY
NAME IS BROOKS ALLEN AND I
SERVED AS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION. AS PRESCRIBING
EDUCATION CODES STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION STOPS POLICY FOR THE
GOVERNANCE OF THE STATE'S
KINDERGARTEN THROUGH GRADE
TWELVE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM.
OUR BOARD HAS ELEVEN MEMBERS
ALL OF WHOM WERE APPOINTED BY
THE. WHO SERVES A ONE YEAR TO.
OUR STATE SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION LEAD TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT EDUCATION
ALSO SERVES AS THE STATE BOARD
EXECUTIVE OFFICER INSPECTOR.
THE STATE BOARD SETS KEY TWELVE
EDUCATION POLICY IN AREAS OF
STANDARDS CURRICULUM FRAMEWORKS
INSTRUCTION MATERIALS
ASSESSMENT AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
REPORT ALSO ADOPTS REGULATIONS
AND TAKES ACTIONS TO IMPLEMENT
A WIDE VARIETY OF PROGRAMS
CREATED BY LEGISLATORS. IN
ADDITION THE STATE BOARD HAS
AUTHORITY TO GRANT LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCY REQUEST FOR
WAIVERS OF CERTAIN PROVISIONS
OF THE STATE EDUCATION CODE OR
TITLE FIVE REGULATIONS. MEMBERS
OF THE STATE BORDER ARE SERVED
BY PROFESSIONAL STAFF INCLUDING
MYSELF IS EXACTLY DIRECTOR AND
CHIEF COUNSEL AND OTHERS WHO
APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNMENT.
THOSE OF US IN CERVANTES
APPOINTED POSITIONS ALSO
CERTAINLY ADVISORY CAPACITY TO
THE GOVERNOR ADMINISTRATION ALL
K. TWELVE MATTERS. IN SHORT WE
SIT AT THE INTERSECTION OF
POLICY IMPLEMENTATION AND WORK
CLOSELY WITH OUR COLLEAGUES IN
THE CALIFORNIA PART OF
EDUCATION AS WELL AS ACROSS ALL
OF THE STATE AGENCIES. TO
SUPPORT THE CHILDREN
CALIFORNIA. AND LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TEACHERS
ADMINISTRATORS AND OTHER STAFF
WHO SERVE THEM EVERY DAY.
BROUGH PANDEMIC THIS IS MATT
THAT WE WORKED ESPECIALLY
CLOSELY WITH OUR COLLEAGUES AT
THE CALIFORNIA PARTNER PUBLIC
pHEALTH. SERVICES GOVERNMENT
PARTICIPATION AND OTHERS ON THE
STATE'S SCHOOLS FROLICKING. TO
PROVIDE SAFE AND SUCCESSFUL
SCHOOLS AMERICA'S MOST URGENT
NEEDS AND TO ESTABLISH A
FOUNDATION OF OPPORTUNITY FOR
ALL CHILDREN. ASIAN OF ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHTY SIX AND INITIATIVES
THAT THE LEGISLATURE GOVERNOR
CAMPAIGN IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
ACT. WHILE WORKING IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE DEPARTMENT
BAD TO ENGAGE WITH FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT RUN CIRCUMSTANCES IN
CALIFORNIA AND HELP EXPLAIN THE
NEEDS OF OUR KIDS IN OUR
SCHOOLS. WE'RE WORKING ON
SOLUTIONS TO CHALLENGES BOTH
LONG STANDING AND EMERGING. WE
ARE STRIVING TO ACHIEVE
CALIFORNIA'S BOTH THE LIKE
FLOWSTHROUGH WITH THE GOALS OF
THE FEDERAL AMERICAN RESCUE
PLAN. ELEMENTARY SECONDARY
SCHOOLS EMERGENCY RELIEF FUNDS.
AND THAT IS TO SUPPORT THE SAFE
OPERATION SCHOOLS. AND ACCESS
THE IN PERSON INSTRUCTION. INTO
ADDRESS ACADEMIC SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS OF ALL STUDENTS. IN THIS
WORK WE DEEPLY APPRECIATE OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH ALL OF YOU.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONVERSATION TODAY THANK YOU.
AND JUST GO HOMES DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- SO WITH THAT CONTEXT
THE REQUESTED IN SB ONE SIXTY
SEVEN IS FOR ONE POINT TWO
MILLION ONE TIME FEDERAL ARCA-
AMERICAN RECOVERY. ACT FUNDS-
AS WELL AS SIX POSITIONS- TO
SUPPORT THE WORK THAT THE BOARD
HAS BEEN DOING AROUND AND WILL
CONTINUE TO DO IN THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO SCHOOL YEAR.
AROUND AT COALBED- PANDEMIC
RESPONSE- I WOULD NOTE THAT THE
BOARD HAS NOT RECEIVED ANY
RESOURCES- FOR THIS WORK THAT
THEY'VE BEEN DOING SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC IN
FACT RECEIVED ANY. NEW
RESOURCES SINCE TWENTY ELEVEN
TWELVE- THE COST OF THESE
POSITIONS THE ONE POINT TWO
MILLION IS PROPOSED TO BE
CARVED OUT OF FIFTEEN MILLION
FEDERAL CARPET MINISTRY TO
FUNDS. THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY
ALLOCATED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACT- WE DON'T
BELIEVE AND WE'VE ONFIRMED
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THAT THIS THIS
REALLOCATION OF ONE POINT TWO
MILLION OF THIS FIFTEEN
MILLION. WILL WILL LIMIT THE
DEPARTMENTS ABILITIES TO
EXECUTE ITS RESPONSIBILITIES
PURSUANT TO OUR BACK. I'M FINE
GOING POSITION FORTY IS NOT
CURRENTLY BEING REQUESTED- THE
BOARD WILL HAVE TO
ADMINISTRATIVELY ESTABLISHED
THE POSITIONS FOR THIS ONE YEAR
FUNDING. HOWEVER WE DO
ANTICIPATE- REQUESTING
ADDITIONAL ON GOING FUNDS
THROUGH THE TWENTY TWENTY TO
BUDGET PROCESS UNDERSTANDING
THAT. THE COMMITTEE WOULD
LIKELY- BAD WOULD LIKELY I
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A FULL
BUDGET. STAKEHOLDER PROCESS TO
CONSIDER ON GOING AND GENERAL
FUND- DURING THE PANDEMIC MANY
OF THE CURRENT STAFF OF THE
BOARD HAS BEEN REDIRECTED TO
WORKLOAD- AROUND SCHOOL RE
OPENING- SAFE SCHOOLS FOR ALL
AND STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT. AND
ASSISTING WITH THE DEVELOPMENT
OF STATE PLANS FOR ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT FEDERAL RELIEF FUNDS-
THAT SCHOOLS HAVE RECEIVED AND
THEN PROVIDING GUIDANCE TO
SCHOOLS I'M IN COLLABORATION
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. ON THESE ACTIVITIES
RELATED TO PREPARING RESPONDING
TO THE PANDEMIC ARE ALLOWABLE
EXPENDITURES FOR URBAN MINISTRY
DIFFERENCE. ON IT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE TO ALLOCATE TO THE
STATE BOARD FOR THEIR
SUSTENANCE WORKLOAD. WE ALSO
NOTE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
APPROPRIATED. TENS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS AND DOZENS OF
PETITIONS TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. FOR WORK
IMPLEMENTING- MANY OF THE NEW
PROPOSALS. THAT WERE IN THE
BUDGET THIS YEAR. AS WELL AS IN
RECOGNITION OF THE GREAT WORK
THAT THEY'RE DOING RIGHT NOW
DURING THE PANDEMIC. AND WE SEE
THIS AS A VERY SIMILAR TYPE OF
ALLOCATION. MISTER ALAN AND I
ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE ON
THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I WILL GO TO L.
A. O. ANY COMMENTS MILLENNIAL.
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
BRIAN BROWN WITH THE L. A. WE
DON'T HAVE ANY PREPARED REMARKS
ON ANY OF THESE BILLS BUT WE DO
HAVE A TEAM OF OUR FOLKS HERE
AVAILABLE SHOULD YOU OR THE
OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE
QUESTIONS. GREAT THANK YOU LET
ME JUST TURN OVER TO THE
COMMUNITY. QUESTIONS MR FALL.
BUT I THINK IT WAS CHAIR. I
WANT TO COMMEND YOU ON THE WORK
THAT SAY YOU PUT IN OVER THE
PAST FEW MONTHS CERTAINLY IS NO
EASY TASK- INFO IN TERMS OF THE
QUESTIONS I HAVE I'LL JUST JUMP
FROM- TRAILER BILL THE TRAILER
BILL AND- IN THE MAYBE WE JUST-
LEAD TO I GUESS WE'LL SEE WHERE
THE QUESTIONS GO BUT IN TERMS
OF THE RESOURCES BILL- AS
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
CONTINUED APPROPRIATIONS WHICH
IS SOMETHING THAT- FOR US IN
THE ASSEMBLY REPUBLICANS THAT
WE'VE BEEN ASKING FOR. BUT IN
TERMS OF- THE DROUGHT. FOCUSING
ON THAT FOR A MOMENT- CERTAINLY
WE'RE FACING A VERY SEVERE
DROUGHT CONDITIONS- BY THE MOST
SEVERE WE'VE WE'VE HAD SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN. WHAT IT
TO THE DEPARTED FINANCE WHAT IS
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN. TO
ADDRESS WATER STORAGE IS THERE
ANY FUNDING IN THIS. BUDGET FOR
WHAT ADDITIONAL WATER STORAGE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION- MR
FONG I'LL TURN THAT QUESTION
THE ANSWER TO OVER TO SERGIO A
DEALER FOR SOME DETAILS. HI
GOOD MORNING SIR DO I GOT WITH
THE PART OF FINANCE SO THIS
BUDGET DOES NOT INCLUDE ANY
SPECIFIC ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
WATER STORAGE. HOWEVER I DO
WANNA TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE OF THE PROP ONE FUNDING
WHICH I DON'T HAVE BEEN PART OF
THAT DISCUSSION OVER THE PAST
FEW HEARINGS SO THERE WAS. TWO
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
THAT WAS AWARDED OR THAT WAS-
ALLOCATED AND PART OF PROP ONE
THERE'S SEVEN- PROJECT THAT
WERE CUT CONDITIONALLY AWARDED
AND RIGHT NOW THOSE PROJECTS
ARE GOING- BEFORE THE WATER
COMMISSION. TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL DETAILS TO BE ABLE
TO- CANCEL STATUTE THE PROJECT
AND GET BASICALLY THE GREEN
LIGHT TO MOVE FORWARD TO THE
NEXT STEP. AND SO THAT THAT THE
OCCURRING OVER THE NEXT TWO
MONTHS- AND- PROP ONE HAD A
DEADLINE OF. BY JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THAT WOULD NEED TO
BE COMPLETED AND THEN AFTER
THAT WE ACTUALLY ANTICIPATE ALL
SEVEN PROJECTS. WOULD RECEIVE
THE APPROVAL AT THIS POINT IN
TIME. AND THEN THOSE PROJECTS
AND MOVE FORWARD WITH- THE
ADDITIONAL- KIND OF PERMITTING
AND THEN CONSTRUCTION NEEDED SO
THOSE SENATE PROJECT OUT PART
OF THAT THE PROP ONE FUNDING.
WITH TWO POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS OTHER KIND OF IN THE Q.
WORKING THROUGH THE PROCESS BUT
THE NEXT TWO MONTHS BASICALLY-
BUT PIVOTAL POINT. FOR THOSE
PROJECTS TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THE
FINAL DOCUMENTS GET FINAL
APPROVAL. AT THE MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE PROJECT. SO I
APPRECIATE THE TO PROP ONE BY.
IT'S THE WAY THE FOR A MINOR
STANDING IS THE PROBLEM FUND
WILL COME ALL THESE PROJECTS.
IS THAT TRUE. SO AT THAT POINT
WE WOULD THEN HAVE TO
SUPPLEMENT THEM. SO THAT I
GUESS A BIT GOES BACK TO MY
ORIGINAL POINT OF WHY DOES THE
ADMINISTRATION NOT BELIEVE
THERE NEEDS TO BE ANY FUNDING
FOR WATER STORAGE IN THIS
CURRENT BUDGET TO SUPPLEMENT
WHAT WAS IN PROP ONE. YEAH I
THINK WELL NOTED THAT PART OF
THE PROBLEM REQUIREMENTS IT
DOES- THE PROJECTS WHICH ARE.
HI COMMITTEE WATER DISTRICTS
ARE THE ONE PUTTING FOR THE
PROJECT THEY DO NEED A SO. KIND
OF WHAT ADDITIONAL FINANCING
MECHANISMS IN ADDITION TO THE
TWO POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
A STATE OF PUTTING FORWARD. TO
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THE OTHER
SHARE COST- AND THEN JUST KIND
LAST YEAR ALTHOUGH. THE ENTIRE
WATER PACKAGE THAT BE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE WORKED- INCLUDE IN
THE JUNE BUDGET AND A COMBINED
WITH THE BUDGET. IS OFF FIVE
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS I GO
TO LOOK TO- KIND OF MANY
DIFFERENT DROUGHT. WATER SUPPLY
WATER RELIABILITY- TYPE
PROGRAMS- BUT AGAIN YOU KNOW
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF MONEY AVAILABLE FOR WATER
STORAGE. THAT IS CURRENTLY
GOING THROUGH THE PROCESS. OKAY
SO BUT JUST TO BE CLEAR OF THE
FIVE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
THAT YOU'VE THAT YOU'VE
OUTLINED. NONE THERE'S NOT. ONE
DOLLAR FOR WATER STORE EDITION
WATER STORAGE. NO NOT FOR THE
NOT FOR THE DIGITAL A LARGE
WATER STORAGE PROJECTS NOT.
OKAY- THAT IS THAT IT IS VERY
DISAPPOINTING- IN TERMS OF THE-
THE ALAMEDA. TESLA EXPANSION
AREA AND THE CLOSURE OF THE- AT
THE CARNEGIE S. V. R. A. M. CAN
THE THAT'S THE BUMMER FINANCE
CAN ADMINISTRATION EXPLAINED
WHY THIS AREA IS PROPOSED TO BE
CLOSED AND EXPLAINED WHICH
AREAS ARE BEING CONSIDERED AS
ALTERNATIVES. YES I'LL TRY THAT
AGAIN TO- SERGIO FOR MORE
DETAILS. GOOD MORNING MIKE
MCGINNIS WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- BE ALAMEDA TEST LIKE
TO MENTION AREA HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS HAVING GAS GIVEN
THE CULTURAL AND NATURAL
RESOURCES THAT STAKEHOLDERS
HAVE A- PUSH TO HAVE PRESERVED
AND TO THIS POINT IN TIME. THE
ADMINISTRATION IS COMMITTED TO
PRESERVING THOSE RESOURCES BUT
HAS NOT IDENTIFIED A NEW
LOCATION FOR- WHICH WE ACTIVITY
THIS- TRAILER BILL WOULD
TRANSFER FUNDS. FROM THE
GENERAL FUND TO THAT WHICH WE
TRUST FUND WOULD NOT ACTUALLY
APPROPRIATE FUNDS TO ACQUIRE
ANY NEW- SPACE AT THIS POINT IN
TIME. ANY SUCH REQUEST TO COMES
IN A FUTURE BUDGET PROPOSAL. SO
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THIS
WAS MOVING THROUGH THE POLICY
PROCESS- AT THE LEGISLATURE SO
I'M I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND.
THE KIND OF YOUR YOUR TRADING A
LOT MORE UNCERTAINTY BECAUSE
YOU AS YOU INDICATED THERE IS
NO ALTERNATIVE BEING DISCUSSED
CORD THAT YOU'VE IDENTIFIED. SO
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THE TO THE
OAG COMMUNITY WHO UTILIZES THIS-
RECREATION AREA THERE YOU'RE
ACTUALLY TAKING AWAY-
RECREATION. SO THE ALAMEDA
TESLA EXPANSIONARY IS NOT
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE FOR- EACH
WEEK USE- THE PROPERTY WOULD
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE HAPPEN
YEAH OUR PROCESS IN THAT. THE
GENERAL PLAN WOULD HAVE TO BE
CREATED WE HAVE TO BUILD OUT OF
THE PARK FOURTH WOULD HAPPEN.
WELL THERE'S NOT A SPECIFIC-
NEW PARK THAT IS PROPOSED AS A
PART OF THIS TRAILER BILL THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS RECREATION
IS CURRENTLY EXPLORING-
KENNEDYS WE DO ANTICIPATE THAT
WE'LL HAVE SOMETHING IN MEDIA.
IN THE FUTURE BUDGET. COMMITS
TO A SPECIFIC LOCATION SO THE
EXPANSION IS. CLEARLY NOT BEING
USED BUT CARNEGIE. S. THE
CARNEGIE STATE VEHICULAR
RECREATION AREA IS. THIRTEEN
HUNDRED ACRES OF PROVIDING
EIGHTY MILES OF TRAILS YOU'RE
CLOSING THAT TOO RIGHT. NO AT
CARNEGIE BE OPERATING OUT WHICH
WE AREAS OF CARNEGIE WILL NOT
BE IMPACTED BY THIS. OKAY SO
YOU'RE JUST PRECLUDING THE
EXPANSION. YES THAT IS CORRECT
OKAY- THAT'S STILL DEBATABLE
BUT I I'D- I STILL AM CONCERNED
THAT- YOU'RE YOU'RE ACTUALLY
CLOSING OFFER REDUCING-
RECREATIONAL AREAS BUT IN TERMS
OF- SYKORA AT IN THIS RESOURCES
BILL THERE'S A SEQUEL EXEMPTION
FOR- HABITAT FOR FISH AND
WILDLIFE- AND I'M ASSUMING
THAT'S BECAUSE OF THE DROUGHT.
BUT WHILE THE M. U. S.
ADMINISTRATION SUPPORT SEQUEL
EXEMPTIONS FOR FISH AND
WILDLIFE WHY NOT DO YOU SEE
WHAT EXEMPTIONS FOR- FOR
WILDFIRE PREVENTION AS WELL.
THANKS FOR THE QUESTION TO MY
COLLEAGUES OR YOUR REGULAR
THANK YOU. YES JUGGLER AGAIN OF
THE PART OF FINANCE SO I THINK
IN TERMS OF- WILDFIRE FORCES
GOING TO HELL THE COMMITTEES I
THINK WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND IS THAT THERE IS. A
CURRENTLY- CAL BTP IT'S
BASICALLY- PROCESS TO
STREAMLINE ENVIRONMENTAL-
PROCESS EVEN PERMITTING THAT-
KIND OF CALIFORNIA HAS WORKED
THROUGH THAT BASICALLY%
STREAMLINED THE ENVIRONMENTAL
PROPERTIES FOR THE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF PROJECTS THAT WOULD
GET FUNDED- WITH THE PLAN THAT
WOULD BRING FORWARD. AND I'M
MAKING A TURN OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE I REBEKAH MORKEL
PRIOR LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL ON
THAT CAL BTP PROPER THAT HOW
HOW WE BELIEVE THAT OUR
DRESSES- THE KIND OF THE KIND
OF YOU KNOW SPEAK WITH TYPE-
ACCELERATION. AT AND MAKING
SURE THAT THOSE PROJECTS ARE.
EXPEDITIOUSLY AND I MOVED
QUICKLY. THANK YOU BACK MORE
DEPART OF FINANCE. YES I
BACKING UP WITH SERGIO SAID
THAT THAT HELP YOU KEEP YOUR
THAT EDUCATION- TREATMENT PLAN-
PROGRAMS HAS UNDERTAKEN A
EXPAND THIS PROJECT TO.
STREAMLINE THE PEOPLE PROCESS
WITH THEIR ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
REPORT THEY HAVE A PROGRAM
PROGRAMMATIC YEAH I ARE IN
PLACE THAT NOW ALLOWS.
DIFFICULT PROCESS TO BE TAKEN
FROM MY USUAL TWO YEARS DOWN TO
ABOUT TWO MONTHS AND EVERY
PROJECTS BUT WE UNDERSTAND THAT
GOES THROUGH THIS. A WILDFIRE
FUNDING WILL. BE EVALUATED AS
PART OF THAT PROCESS WHICH
INCORPORATES FISH AND WILDLIFE-
THE STATE WATER BOARD WHICH IS
RECEIVING TWO MILLION DOLLARS
TO COVER ALL OF THEIR PROGRAMS
EACH OF THE NEXT FEW YEARS-
WE'RE ALSO TRYING TO
INCORPORATE THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD AND LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS
IN WITH THIS FUNDING. AND
ESSENTIALLY THAT THE PROCESS
COVERS ALL OF THE SPEAK WHAT
CONSIDERATION BY. ANY PROJECTS
THAT NEED TO GO THROUGH. OKAY
CERTAINLY EFFORT WE'VE FROM FOR
THAT THAT ENDED THAT SEEK WHAT
IS CAN AND CONTINUES TO BE A
ROADBLOCK- TO DO THESE
VEGETATION MEASURE PROJECTS-
ARE YOU HEARING THE SAME THING
ARE YOU ARE YOU ARE YOU IS IT
YOUR POSITION THAT THIS IS
WORKING. THAT IS THAT THE
STREAMLINED PROCESS IS WORKING.
YES IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT
THIS IS ALREADY IN PLACE AND
THAT THE VISION WHILE THE BUT
I'M ALRIGHT BUT ALREADY AND ALL
ALREADY IN PLACES I MEAN IT'S
WORKING. IT IS ARE YOU ARE YOU
SAYING. THAT THAT THIS PROCESS
IS WORKING THAT THAT THE SEQUEL
PROCESS IS STREAMLINED TO THE
POINT WHERE FORSTER'S ARE HAPPY
WITH THE PROCESS. OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT ALL OF THESE
PROJECTS THAT ARE BEING
PERMITTED ESPECIALLY THROUGH
THE EARLY ACTION FUNDING
ALREADY EXPERIENCING THAT
DESTRY MINAHASA. OKAY SO WE'RE
GONNA SEE MORE ACRES BEING
TREATED THE NEXT TIME YOU
TESTIFIED BEFORE US. AND WE
ALSO HAVE PRELIMINARY NINETEEN
TWENTY NUMBERS AND ARE WAITING
ON TWENTY TWENTY ONE NUMBERS
BUT OUR UNDERSTANDING AND BUT
OUR AD ACRES TREATED JUMPS
QUITE SIGNIFICANTLY LAUGHTER.
BECAUSE OF THAT ABOUT. IF THE
CHAIRMAN TOLD ME IF I CAN JUMP
TO THE L. A. L. IS THE SEQUEL
EXEMPTION IS THE SEEK WHAT THE
STREAMLINED SECRET PROCESS
ISN'T WORKING. GOOD MORNING MR
FONG BRYAN BROWN AGAIN WITH THE
L. A. O. THIS IS NOT SOMETHING
SPECIFICALLY WE'VE LOOKED AT
BUT WE CAN- WE CAN LOOK INTO IT
IS MORE DETAIL AND GET BACK TO
THE- TEAM TO THE COMMITTEE IN
THE FUTURE. OKAY I APPRECIATE
THAT I THINK SEEK WERE IS
BELIEVE WE'RE HERE AT PETER
LEE- ESPECIALLY AS WE ARE
DEALING WITH A CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRE SEASON RIGHT NOW THAT.
SEEK WORK CONTINUES TOBE A
ROADBLOCK SO I CERTAINLY WOULD
APPRECIATE ANY. DATA OR
EVIDENCE THAT SEEK WAS NOT A
PROBLEM- IT SEEMS TO ME THAT. I
HAVEN'T SEEN UP UP UP UP
PROJECT APPROVED IN TWO MONTHS
SO THAT SEEMS TO BE A VERY.
AGGRESSIVE TIMELINE BUT I
CERTAINLY WOULD. WOULD HOPE
THAT. MORE PROJECTS TO BE
APPROVED IN THAT TIME FRAME-
LET'S SEE HERE. IN TERMS OF
THE- THERE'S BEEN THIS BILL IN
THE RESOURCE BUILT THE BILL
ALSO EXPEDITES THE REMOVAL OF
HYDROELECTRIC THIS FOR THE
HYDROELECTRIC FACILITIES AND
DAMS ON THE KLAMATH RIVER. SO
IT SEEMS. FRUSTRATING THAT
WE'RE EXPEDITING WE'RE NOT
EXPEDITING THE CONSTRUCTION OF
WATER STORAGE OR WOULD EVEN
PUTTING ANY MONEY INTO WATER
STORAGE. BUT WE- BUT WE'RE
WILLING TO REMOVE FACILITIES
AND DAMS IS THAT CORRECT. BUT
SIR DR FLOWER BUT PART OF
FINANCE- IF I DO MAKE CLEAR BY
A LITTLE BIT ON THE CLIMATE
THAT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE SO
THAT PROCESS THE PROJECT I. P.
ALREADY WENT TO SEE WHAT AND-
RIGHT NOW IT'S GOING THROUGH-
APPROVAL THROUGH THROUGH FOR IT
THROUGH THE FEDERAL PROCESS AND
THERE ARE CONCERNS THAT BACK
ADDITIONAL APPROVAL WITHIN-TRIGGER A SECOND VEHICLE. WHEN
THERE'S PROBABLY THIRTY WENT
THROUGH THE QUOTE AFTER
BASICALLY WHAT THIS TRAILER
DOES ACKNOWLEDGE THAT EKITI
WENT TO SEE QUITE AND IF THERE
IS ANOTHER KIND OF FEDERAL
APPROVAL THAT THAT WOULD
TRIGGER YOU CAN LITERALLY WENT
TO SEE WHAT THE IT DOESN'T NEED
TO GO THROUGH IT AGAIN AS- SO
AGAIN YOU KNOW IT IT DID GO TO
RECYCLE ONCE ALREADY IT IS
MAKING SURE THAT WE DON'T
FURTHER SLOW SLOW THE PROJECT
DOWN IF SOMEHOW THERE THE
ADDITIONAL TRIGGER THAT.
POTENTIALLY WOULD BE NO
DEVELOPING. A RIDDLE AND YEARS
OF DELAYS. OKAY I AG I GUESS
AND EVEN TO COMMIT TO POINT
THAT WOULD EXPLAIN THAT WERE.
THINGS THE- APPARENTLY YOU GUYS
LIKE BUT WE'RE NOT EXPEDITING
THINGS THAT YOU DON'T LIKE BUT
THE THINGS THAT YOU DON'T LIKE
OR THINGS THAT ARE NECESSARY.
SO I THINK THAT'S THE POINT.
I'M TRYING TO MAKE. I IN TERMS
OF JUMPING TO. THE SB ONE SIXTY
TWO- IS THERE A SPECIFIC
CRITERIA IN WHICH THEM THE SIX
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT HAS TO
BE USED FOR AS BE SPENT ON
CERTAIN THINGS IT DOESN'T HAVE
TO BE DONE- THROUGH THIS FUND
OR CAN IT BE USED FOR OTHER
THINGS. QUESTION NUMBER TWO
DANIEL BRANDON FOR FURTHER
DETAILS. HI PATRICK TOPPING
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- AT THE
END THIS IS A PROGRAM USING
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN ACT FUNDS
AND SO THEREFORE MUST ALIGN
WITH. AMERICA RIGHT MAC RESCUE
PLAN ACT GUIDELINES BUT- THESE
DOLLARS ARE AN ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSAL. THIS THIS IS SO IT IT
DOESN'T HAVE TO IT DOESN'T HAVE
TO BE USED FOR THESE FOR THE
FUND. FOR THIS ECONOMIC FUND.
KNEES FONG ARE YOU THESE FUNDS
ARE PROPOSAL THE MINISTRATION
HAS USE. AS PROPOSED TO USE
THESE DOLLARS FOR. OKAY SO BUT
THERE'S NO STRINGS ATTACHED I
GUESS BEFORE AND THE FOR THE
FOR GOVERNMENT PROVIDED THIS
FUNDS THAT COULD BE USED FOR
YOU GUYS CHOSE TO USE IT FOR
THIS FUND AS AS I GUESS THAT'S
ON MY BIKE. YES THAT IS CORRECT
OKAY SO THEN. WHY DOES THAT
THIS. PROGRAM WHY DOES IT NOT
INVOLVE THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD WHICH YOU
WOULD THINK WOULD BE PART OF.
THAT WOULD BE PART OF THE MIX
IT WOULD BE NEEDED TO BE PART
OF THE MIX AND YOU WHY DID YOU
LEAVE THEM OUT AND THEN WHY DO
YOU PUT THEM INTO THE- WADI OF
THE EDT LEAD THIS PROGRAM WHEN
I'M NOT SURE THAT ANYONE
BELIEVES THAT THEY HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO ACTUALLY DELIVER
RESULTS. SO TRY TO ADDRESS
THOSE EACH OF THOSE QUESTIONS
ANSWERED LIKE THERE'S A COUPLE
OF THEM IN THERE AND PLEASE LET
ME KNOW IF I SKIP ANYTHING.
GIVEN THE FIRST ONE SO THIS ONE
IS THIS PROGRAM IS GOING TO BE
THE **** BOOKKEEPING ROLE THIS
IS GOING TO BE HANDLED BY THE
E. WORKFORCE. SERVICES BRANCH.
WHICH IS UNRELATED TO EDIE'S
CORPORATIONS OF YOU WHY THE I.
LIKE THE UNIVERSE- THOSE-
REGULARLY THE WORKFORCE
SERVICES BRANCH HAS ABOUT
FIFTEEN HUNDRED EMPLOYEES AND
MANAGES HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND WORKFORCE
INNOVATION AND OPPORTUNITY ACT
A REAL FUNDING SO WE BELIEVE
THERE ARE MORE THAN CAPABLE OF
ADMINISTERING YEAH PAPERWORK
FOR THIS FUN ASIDE FROM THAT-
INTERAGENCY LEADER TEAM OF
LABOR AGENCY GOV IS AN OPR WILL
BE- AND RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
POLICY DEVELOPMENT RELATED. AS
FOR THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD- I THINK THIS IS GOING TO
MAKE THIS IS NOT. A WORK FORCE
TRAINING PROPOSAL IS AN
ECONOMIC RECOVERY PROPOSAL AND
THEREFORE WORK FIRST BOARD WILL
CERTAINLY- LABOUR NEC MEMBER
LIE ON THEM. FOR INFORMATION
ABOUT SOME OF THE PROGRAMS IN
THEIR REQUIREMENTS TO BANK WITH
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
PROGRAMS WHERE AFTER
APPLICABLE. BUT IT IS NOT
REALLY UNDER THEIR PURVIEW.
OKAY SO THEN WHO DETERMINES. HI
I THINK THE PHRASE IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
CODED THAT DID THAT THE FUNDS
WOULD GO TO THESE REGIONS SO
WHO WHO'S WHO DETERMINES WHERE
THE FUNDS GO. SURE THE PHRASE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
CLIMATE NINETEEN IS DEFINED BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND IS
INCLUDED HERE TO ALIGN WITH
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN ACT ENDS.
OF THE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
ADMINISTRATION RELEASED A
NOTICE OF FUNDING AVAILABILITY
DETERMINE EVERY REGION IN THE
U. S. HAS BEEN AFFECTED BY
KOGAN AND- PROVE ON THIS TOPIC
WILL BE REFLECTED IN THE ART
AND ARCADE PROCESS. SAID THAT
THE PURPOSE OF THIS PROGRAM IS
TO PROVIDE IMMEDIATE RELIEF
BUT- THE READING OF AT LEAST
THE READING OF THE LANGUAGE
ALLOWS- THE BAG ALLOWS THE
RECIPIENT TO HAVE FIVE YEARS TO
EXPAND THE FUNDS IS THAT
CORRECT. CORRECT YEAH THESE-
THIS TIME LINE HERE THE TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX STATES
ARE THERE TO ALIGN WITH FEDERAL
ARE BUYING CONFERENCE- ASIDE
FROM ALLOWING GUIDELINE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION- ALIGNING WITH
THIS FINAL GUNS- ALLOWED THE
REGIONS THAT HAVE THE MOST
FLEXIBILITY TO PLAN FOR THEIR
ECONOMIC THAT. NEEDS FROM THE-
TO RECOVER FROM THE PANDEMIC
OKAY. I WOULD JUST WOULD JUST
SAY THAT IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
THERE SIX ARE MILLION DOLLARS
AVAILABLE THAT AND IF THAT THE
AND THE GOAL IS IMMEDIATE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY I THINK THERE
ARE PROBABLY OTHER THINGS TO DO
I WOULD SAY MAYBE- RESTORING
SOME OF THE TAX CREDITS AND
RESEARCH DEVELOPMENT MAYBE YOU.
BEEN DOING IT VIA NET OPERATING
LOSS DEDUCTION DEDUCTIONS THAT
WERE TAKEN AWAY LET THE LAST-
BUDGET I FEEL LIKE THOSE THINGS
IT PROVIDES A MORE IMMEDIATE
RELIEF- DAN THANK CREATING A
WHOLE NEW- GRANT PROGRAMS- AND-
TOOK THE JOB. TO A- THAT'S THE.
ONE SIXTY- CERTAINLY THE TO THE
BERMAN FINDS THE REMOVAL OF
FIREARMS FROM CONVICTED FELONS
AND OTHER PROHIBITED PERSONS-
YOU WILL NOW HAVE STRUGGLED TO
STAFFING ISSUES- AND AT THE
CURRENT ATTORNEY GENERAL IS
TRYING TO CHANGE THAT HAS. THAT
BARGAINING UNIT APPROACHED. THE
ADMINISTRATION TO INCREASE THE
SALARIES OF THOSE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS. YES CAN I
TURN THAT QUESTION TOO MERRY
ALTERMAN WHO WORKS IN OUR
COMPENSATION AND THANK YOU. I
AM VERY WELL TRAINED DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION SO FOR I'M THE DOJ
FIVE BATTERY BY SPECIFICALLY
FOR THE SPECIAL AGENTS- IF
THERE ARE ANY PENDING REQUESTS
ON OTHER ITEMS WE DON'T
DISCLOSE THAT INFORMATION-
UNTIL WE'VE ACTUALLY REACHED AN
AGREEMENT. BUT I GUESS E. THERE
IS A KNOWLEDGE MEANT THAT THERE
IS SIGNIFICANT STAFFING ISSUES
WITH THIS WITH THE PROGRAM.
WHEN I AM NOT FAMILIAR WITH
THAT PROGRAM AND SO I MAY HAVE
TO TURN IT OVER TO ANOTHER
COLLEAGUE HAS THE ASSIGNMENT.
DOES ANYONE ACKNOWLEDGE THEIR
STAFFING ISSUES OR IS THAT. IS
THAT NOT AN ISSUE FOR THE
MINISTRATION. SORRY THIS IS AMY
JARVIS WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND I AGREE WITH THIS
WHOLE TIME AND THAT WE ARE
UNABLE TO DISCLOSE ANYTHING
RELATED TO THE BARGAINING
PROCESS BUT WE ARE AWARE. OF
AND SOME ISSUES WITH THEIR
ABILITY TO HIRE AND RETAIN AND
THOSE CLASSIFICATIONS WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
CONVERSATIONS WILL BE ONGOING
OKAY I MEAN CERTAINLY I I'M NOT
ASKING YOU TO DIVULGE.
SENSITIVE INFORMATION I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WAS WAS-
COGNIZANT OF THIS AND THAT THEY
WERE- THERE WAS ON I WAS ON
YOUR RADAR SO I APPRECIATE
THAT- JUMPING TO THE EDUCATION
TRAILER- SB ONE SIXTY SEVEN- I
KNOW THIS IS AN AREA THAT'S
THAT'S VERY NEAR AND DEAR TO
THE CHAIRS- HEART BUT IN TERMS
OF THE INDEPENDENT STUDY. WHAT
WAS THE IMPETUS FOR THESE
CHANGES INDEPENDENT STUDY WHAT
WAS IT WAS THE- AS THE PRICE IS
NOT WORKING WAS IT IS IT IS
WHAT IS NECESSARY BECAUSEOF.
OF THINGS THAT WERE HAPPENING
WITHIN DIFFERENT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CAN YOU JUST GIVE ME
KIND OF A SENSE OF WHY THAT WHY
THESE CHANGES WERE NECESSARY.
CHARLTON THE QUESTION TO JUST A
COUPLE. WE JUST GOT HOMES
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE MAJOR
CHANGES THAT WERE MADE IN SB
ONE SIXTY SEVEN ARE REFLECTIVE
AND INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE
COLLECTED THROUGHOUT THE SUMMER
AFTER THAT. ENACTMENT OF THE
ORIGINAL HONEST TRAILER BILL
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
EDUCATION HONEST TRAILER BILL.
AND IT WAS NEVER THE INTENT OF
THE ADMINISTRATION- TO NOT
PROVIDE APPORTIONMENT TO AND
LEDS ARE PROVIDING INDEPENDENT
STUDY STUDENTS WHO WERE
QUARANTINED- NOTED TO IT TOO TO
NOT PROVIDE THEM WITH THE
FORTUNATE FOR THAT- AND SO THAT
THE MAJOR CHANGE IN THIS BILL
WOULD ENSURE THAT WHEN A LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCY IS PROVIDING
THAT INDEPENDENT STUDY TO THAT
QUARANTINE STUDENT THEY CAN
RECEIVE THAT APARTMENT- THIS IS
REALLY CONNECTED TO- I THINK
WITH. A SHARED PRIORITY AMONG
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT STUDENTS
ARE RECEIVING A CONTINUITY
CONSTRUCTION EVEN WHILE THEY'RE
QUARANTINED- AS OPPOSED TO YOU
KNOW GOING HOME AND NOT YOU
KNOW HAVING ANY KIND OF
INSTRUCTION MOTHER IN
QUARANTINE- THERE SOME
ADDITIONAL CHANGES THAT WERE
MADE- SPECIFICALLY AROUND
EXTENDING- SUBSTITUTE TEACHER-
AT THE ABILITY FOR SUCH A
TEACHER TO TEACH IN A SINGLE
CLASSROOM FROM THIRTY DAYS TO
SIXTY DAYS IN RECOGNITION BALK-
HER EXPERIENCING A- SHORTAGE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- AS WELL
AS SOME OTHER. TECHNICAL
CHANGES- BUT HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE ON
ON THE SO I GUESS THAT TO JUMP
INTO THE SPECIFIC THERE'S
LIMITATIONS TO THAT TO THE G.
J. THIRTEEN PROCESS WRITINGS
EIGHT THAT THAT'S CLEARLY
OUTLINED WHICH ALLOWS- SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO- TELL ASK REFLECTS.
DO TO A NORMALLY ITS USE FOR-
NETTED DISASTERS OTHER THINGS
RIGHT WAS THE J. THIRTEEN
PROCESS NOT WORKING TO THE
POINT WHERE YOU NEED TO MAKE
THESE CHANGES YOU WOULD THINK
THAT. A PANDEMIC WOULD ALSO BE
A REASON WHY SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WE USED TO DATE THIRTEEN
PROCESS. CERTAINLY SO- THE
REASON WHY WE MADE THAT CHANGE
WAS LESS ABOUT- SOMETHING NOT
WORKING A MORE ABOUT PROVIDING
CLARITY. AND TO THE EDUCATION
FIELD- AND THEN ALSO INSURING
THAT WE'RE NOT DISINCENTIVE
FIGHTING THE PRODUCTION OF
INDEPENDENT STUDY SOME KIND OF.
INSTRUCTIONAL CONTINUITY WHILE
STUDENTS ARE I'M CURRENTLY IN
FOR COVE IT SO IN THAT THE G.
THIRTEEN A PROCESS FOR THOSE
WHO ARE UNFAMILIAR IS- L. I. IT
AWAY THAT- SCHOOLS CAN. RE
CAPTURE AN AVERAGE DAILY
ATTENDANCE THAT'S LOST DURING
TIMES OF EMERGENCY- SCHOOLS ARE
NOT REQUIRED TO. PROVIDE ANY
SORT OF INSTRUCTION IN ORDER TO
RECAP FOR THE EIGHTY EIGHT
JUST- SIMPLY TO IDENTIFY THAT
THERE IS AN EMERGENCY. SO THE
PURPOSE OF THE CHANGES THERE
WAS TO CLARIFY THAT THE G.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY- IS NOT
APPROPRIATE IN. THE CASE OF
KOPET- QUARANTINE BECAUSE THE
STATE IS GIVING A LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES THE
ABILITY TO EARN. THAT
INDEPENDENT STUDY CREDIT THE
EIGHTY EIGHT THROUGH
INDEPENDENT STUDY- ED. AS A
SPECIFIED AND THE OTHER
SECTIONS OF THIS BILL SB ONE
SIXTY SEVEN. SO SCHOOLS DON'T
HAVE SCHOOLS HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO EARN THAT
CREDIT- REGARDLESS OF. THE G.
THIRTEEN PROCESS THAT'S
CLARIFYING THAT THAT'S NOT AN
APPROPRIATE PATH FOR SCHOOLS TO
TAKE ALSO ENSURING THAT SCHOOLS
ARE AREN'T INCENTIVIZED TO. TRY
TO GO DOWN THAT PATH- AND NOT
PROVIDE SERVICES INSTRUCTIONAL
CONTINUITY TO STUDENTS WHILE
THEY'RE QUARANTINED. OKAY- SO
IT ONE OF THE ONE THE-
EXEMPTION IS A COURSE WHEN
THERE'S A TEACHER SHORTAGE BUT
THAT DOES NOT APPLY TO YOU-
CLASSIFIED STAFF AS WELL
THERE'S A SHORTENED CLASS
STORAGE OF CLASSIFIED STAFF-
I'M SURE YOU'RE AWARE THAT.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE A HUGE
SHORTAGE OF BUS DRIVERS WHICH
CERTAINLY AFFECTS A LOT OF
STUDENTS BUT SPECIAL EDUCATION
STUDENTS SPECIFICALLY SO. WOOD
THIS BILL ALLOW SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- TO USE THIS PROCESS
TO GET TO FOR ASSISTANCE AND
FORGET CLASSIFIED STEP BACK TO
THE SCHOOLS. YES AND CERTAINLY
AND SAID THAT THE I BELIEVE THE
LANGUAGE THAT WE USE TO REFER
TO STAFF SO SCHOOL STAFF AS
OPPOSED TO JUST CERTIFICATED
STAFFERS ARE TEACHERS- YOU KNOW
WE'VE WE'VE BEEN I I'VE BEEN
PRIVY TO SOME MEETINGS THAT-
ARE IRAN. AT PARTNERS OVER THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION HAVE
BEEN HAVING WITH MANY COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS SUPERINTENDENTS- AND
THAT THERE'S BEEN QUITE A LOT
OF CONVERSATION AROUND THE
STAFFING ISSUES THAT ALLEYS ARE
HAVING AND YOU'RE YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT- YOU KNOW
THERE ARE SPECIFIC SPECIFICALLY
IN SPECIAL EDUCATION. THERE ARE
SOME REAL AND THAT THE
SHORTAGES THAT WERE ALREADY
THERE BEEN EXACERBATED- AND SO
I KNOW THAT THE STATE BOARD OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
HAVE BEEN DOING A LOT OF GREAT
WORK TRYING TO HELP FOLKS WORK
THROUGH. ON SOME OF THESE
DIFFICULTIES AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE AWARE OF ALL THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
THEM I'M CONNECTING THEM WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S ANYTHING
THAT'S NEEDED AROUND YOU ALONG
THE LINES OF TESTING. ON OUR
CONTACT RAISING THAT RESOURCES
CAN BE PROVIDED- AND SO WE'RE
WE'RE VERY AWARE OF THAT ISSUE
IN AND MADE A VERY CONSCIOUS
DECISION TO- HAVE THAT. THE
ABILITY TO CALL THAT WAIVER
APPLY TO ALL STAFF NOT JUST
TEACHERS OKAY APPRECIATE THAT
I'D CERTAINLY IF YOU KEEP US
UPDATED I KNOW THAT- OUR
SUPERINTENDENTS AND OUR
PRINCIPALS ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE- THE SHORTAGES ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT COMES THE BUS DRIVERS
TRANSPORTATION IS CERTAINLY A
BIG DEAL- BUT ESPECIALLY IN
RURAL AREAS- LIKE KERN. JUMPING
TO- SB EIGHT ONE SIXTY NINE-
CAN SOMEONE PROVIDE SOME.
BACKGROUND IN TERMS OF- THE
PROHIBITION ON PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS ON. ON UNIVERSITY
HOUSING WHY THAT WHY THAT'S
THERE. MIGHT AS AS A SERI. YEAH
I WILL TURN UP QUESTION TO
REBECCA- KIRK THANK YOU.
REBECCA CURTAINS APARTMENT OF
FINANCE. REGARDING YOUR
QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT
PROHIBITION IT IS INTENDED TO
ENSURE THAT STATE FUNDS
SUPPORTING THE STUDENT HOUSING
PROJECTS THE THAT PROGRAM WOULD
BE USED TO SUPPORT THE PUBLIC
INTEREST AND WE WOULD KNOW THAT
THE PROHIBITION DOES NOT
PRECLUDE THE SEGMENTS FROM
ENTERING INTO PARTNERSHIPS WITH
OTHER PUBLIC ENTITIES OR WITH
NONPROFIT ENTITIES. OKAY SO
IT'S ONLY. IT'S ONLY PROHIBITS
THIS FUND FROM BEING USED FOR
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS NOT
IT DOESN'T PREVENT UNIVERSITIES
TO- CALIFORNIA VERSUS TO ENTER
INTO- PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS FOR HOUSING
BROADLY. THAT IS CORRECT THE
PROHIBITION IS SPECIFIC TO
PROJECTS FUNDED WITH THE
STUDENT HOUSING GRANT PROGRAM
BEING ESTABLISHED IN THE
TRAILER BILL. BUT I GUESS I
GUESS GOING BACK TO THE- GUESS
THE DIRECTIONAL THRUST OF THE
QUESTION WHY WOULD WE WANT TO
PREVENT. THE USE OF STATE THE
STATE FUNDS IF THERE'S A IF
THERE'S A GOOD PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP WHY WOULD WE WANT
TO PREVENT THAT. I WOULD SAY
THAT. THE INTENT IS JUST TO
KEEP FOCUSED KEEP THOSE
PROBLEMS FOCUSED ON SUPPORTING
PUBLIC ENTITIES OR A NONPROFIT
AGREEMENTS THAT THE SEGMENTS
MAY ENTER INTO PUBLIC- INTO
PARTNERSHIP WITH. AND FOR
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON OF MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE L. A. L. OR.
THE LEGISLATIVE SIDE HAVE
ANYTHING TO ADD. CHRIS FERGUSON
WITH FINANCE AYE I WOULD ADD
ONE OTHER ADDITIONAL NOTED THAT
IS UNDER THE GRANT PROGRAM THE
EXPECTATION IS THAT THE STATE
IS SUPPORTING THE COST TO
CONSTRUCT THE FACILITIES AND
UNDER THAT APPROACH IF WE'RE
PAYING FOR THE ENTIRETY OF THAT
FACILITY IT IS IT IS IN THE IN
THE INTEREST OF UNIVERSITIES
THAT THEY MAIN CONTROL OF THAT
FACILITY. OKAY. I GUESS I GUESS
MY CONCERN IS PROHIBITING
SOMETHING THAT COULD BE A GOOD
THING IT'S IT SEEMS- KAREN TO
IT OF BUT- JUMPING TO. THE
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR- WERE FROM
THE FIVE POINT OUR HIGHER ON
THE BUDGET BUDGET HAD MISTER
CHAIR. OF IN TERMS OF- MINUS
THAT SO IN IN THIS IN THIS BILL
THERE'S A DO YOU INDICATED
THERE'S NINE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
ALLOCATED- TO WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AND THAT'S SO THAT
FUNDING IS ALL DEDICATED TO ONE
OF OUR PREVENTION RIGHT IT
CAN'T GO TO OTHER THINGS I'M
NOTICING OTHER PROVISIONS THAT
SAY. THAT WILDFIRE PREVENTION
IS ELIGIBLE FOR THOSE FINDINGS
BUT THEN THERE'S OTHER THINGS.
THAT ARE ASSOCIATED OTHER USES
THAT ARE NOT WILDFIRE
PREVENTION SPECIFIC SO I GUESS
THAT MY QUESTION IS ARE YOU
COUNTING THOSE THAT OR ARE YOU
ARE OR HOWEVER THESE DEDICATED
TO OF OUR PREVENTION. YES THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER THERE IS.
INDEED THE NINE HUNDRED EIGHTY
EIGHT MILLION OR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO FOR ADDITIONAL
WILDFIRE FORCED RESILIENCE
INVESTMENTS AND I'LL TURN THE-
THAT MORE DETAILED ANSWER OVER
TO MY COLLEAGUES AND YOU KNOW I
GET LARA OR- THE PROJECT THAT
WOULD FALL UNDER THAT. YES
THEIR GENERAL FUND FINANCED
YEAH THIS NINE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY EIGHT MILLION WHICH OF
IN ADDITION TO THAT EARLY
ACTION A FIVE THIRTY FOUR FOR A
TOTAL OF ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IS ALL FOR. WILDFIRE
PREVENTION OF FOREST RESILIENCE
EFFORTS SO FUNDING TO HELP
CREATE RESILIENT WILDLANDS- TO
DO FUEL BREAKS- COMEDIAN
HARDENING. UP MORE SCIENCE
BASED MANAGEMENT AND STREAMLINE
THE PERMITTING WHICH WE WERE
DISCUSSING A LITTLE BIT
EARLIER- MORE KIND OF CLIMATE
RESILIENT ECONOMIC GROWTH FOR
THE FLOOR SECTOR- WORKFORCE
WORTH FOR SECTOR. AND SO ALL OF
THIS WHOLE PACKAGE- BASICALLY
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
TOTAL WHEN YOU COMBINE THE
EARLY ACTION PUT THE NINE
EIGHTY EIGHT. IS ALL FOR WALTER.
PREVENTION FORCES DOING OKAY.
IN IN TERMS OF THE- I KNOW THAT
THERE'S A REAL WE- IN THIS IN
THIS TRAILER BILL BUT- WHAT
ENTITY IS. IS TASKED TO OVERSEE.
ALL THIS FUNDING AND WHETHER
IT'S WORKING IS IT IS IT IS IT
SOMEONE WITH AND CAL FIRE IS IT
SOMEONE WITHIN DEPARTMENT
FINANCE IS IT SOMEONE WITHIN
THAT RESOURCES ARE WHO IS OR
WHO OR WHAT ENTITY IS TASKED.
TO TRACK ALL THIS FUNDING AND
TO TRACK THE METRICS OF WHAT'S
BEING USED FOR. I BELIEVE UNDER
THE TRAILER BILL IT IDENTIFIED
AS THE NATURALRESOURCE AGENCY
WHO WOULD TRACK AND MONITOR OR
WHO WOULD COLLECT THE
INFORMATION I THINK THAT'S- HOW
THE KIND OF ENTITY THAT WE
FRAMED AS AS THE- ENTITY THAT
WOULD GATHER THE INFORMATION TO
THEM TO THE ANNUAL REPORTING.
THAT WE'RE PUTTING INTO THE
TRAILER BILL BUT AGAIN LIKE FOR
EVERY INDIVIDUAL PROGRAM YOU
KNOW YOU HAVE THE DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS- WARD MINISTERING
THE PROGRAMMED AND SO EVERY
DEPARTMENTS ULTIMATELY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR OWN
PROGRAMS BUT IT'S CAUGHT FIRE
WAS PART OF THAT FISH AND
WILDLIFE COULDN'T EVERYBODY
HAS. GOT DIFFERENT PIZZA THAT
THE LARGER PUZZLE- I THINK IN
TERMS OF THE KIND OF OLD-
REPORTING IT WOULD BE THAT
NECTARIES AGENCY AS- THE LEAD
OVER I THINK THE MAJORITY THE
DEPARTMENT. THIS FUNDING THAT
WOULD GATHER THIS INFORMATION
TO DO THAT MORNING. I HAD I
APPRECIATE THAT THERE ARE A LOT
AGENCIES INVOLVED I THINK THAT
THAT'S THE CONCERN THAT I HAVE
AND MAYBE THAT SOME OF THE
MEMBERS THAT REPRESENT AREAS
THAT ARE ON THAT ARE ON FIRE
RIGHT NOW IS THAT. THAT
COORDINATION IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THINGS ARE BEING DONE AND SO WE
DON'T WANT THE LEFT HANDED NOT
NOT KNOW WHAT THE RIGHT HAND IS
DOING. SO. AND THAT I THINK
THAT'S WHY- HAVING AN- OR SOME.
TASKED WITH TRACKING ALL THIS
AND COORDINATING IT SO THAT
THERE AREN'T ANY BLIND SPOTS.
ASSEMBLY THAT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTAT TO ME THAT WE WOULD
ASK FOR- MOVING FORWARD- I KNOW
I AM- I'M GONNA GOING BACK TO
DROUGHT AND WATER STORAGE BUT-
CAN I ASK ADMINISTRATION WHAT
IS THE STICKING POINT. FOR YOU
ALL IN TERMS OF WHY. THERE
ISN'T MORE OF A DESIRE FOR
WATER STORAGE IS THERE
SOMETHING SPECIFIC THAT YOU
GUYS DON'T WANT. OR WHAT WHAT
IS WHAT'S THE WHAT'S THE
PREDICT WHAT'S THE SPECIFIC
STICKING POINT. SO I'M NOT
TRACKING ANY PARTICULAR
STICKING POINT OTHER THAN THE
FACT THAT THERE'S TWO POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS THAT IS
GOING TO BE GOING OUT FOR THE
SEVEN LARGE PROJECTS THAT ARE
ARE GONNA BE IMPLEMENTED OVER
THE- NEXT FEW YEARS YOU KNOW
THAT ARE CURRENTLY GOING
THROUGH THE APPROVAL PROCESS.
TO GIVE THAT THERE'S AB TWO
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
BILLION DOLLARS THERE'S A LOT
OF DIFFERENT NEEDS AND THE
WATERS BASED ON DEMONSTRATION
PUT OUT- IN TWENTY TWENTY THE
WATER IS GOING PORTFOLIO WHICH
BASICALLY HAVE A PORTFOLIO
STRATEGIES- TO BUILD UP MORE
RESILIENCE IN OUR IN OUR WATER
SYSTEM WORKING WITH LOCALS AND-
AND PARTNERSHIPS AND SO- YOU
JUST ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THERE'S
A LOT OF. DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
THAT THEY HAVE A NEED AND
THERE'S ALREADY TWO POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS THAT IS- SET
ASIDE FOR WATER STORAGE THOUGH-
I DON'T THINK ANY PARTICULAR
STICKING POINT HAVE O WHY. WHY
NOT MORE OTHER THAN A TWO POINT
SEVEN BILLION THAT IS CURRENTLY
SET UP SO LET ME COMPARE MY
LIST WITH YOUR LIST WHAT I THE
SEVEN PROJECTS THAT YOU HAVE
PENDING BEFORE. THE WATER
COMMISSION. SO THE CHINO BASIN
USED ENVIRONMENTAL STORAGE THE
HARDEST WATER PROGRAM. THE KERN-
BROADER WATER STORAGE PROGRAM
THE LOCALES RATHER FOR THE
CHECK A RATHER WARM SITES
RESERVOIR AND WILLOW SPRINGS.
SO YOU'RE SAYING THAT AFTER THE
TWO POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
IS ALLOCATED ASSUMING IT
HAPPENS- THAT THESE SEVEN
PROJECTS ARE GOING TO BECOME
FULLY COMPLETED OPERATIONAL. IF
THEY RECEIVE ALL THE
APPROPRIATE APPROVALS AND THE-
OTHER FINANCING MECHANISMS
WHICH IS PART OF ONE OF THE
REQUIREMENTS THERE AND I MEAN
AT LEAST WE COULD SAY IS THE
TWO POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
IS WOULD BE SET ASIDE FOR THE
PROJECT. BUT AGAIN THESE ARE
NOT YOU KNOW STATE RUN PROJECTS
THE WOULD BE RUN BY THE LOCAL
WATER DISTRICTS AS- ULTIMATELY
YOU KNOW THE PIECE DOES DEPEND
ON ON THE SPEED OF THESE LOCAL
IMPLEMENTERS TO GET THE PROJECT
DONE AS A WE CAN ACTUALLY SPEAK
ON. ON BEHALF OF- KIND OF THE
FEEDER OR WHETHER THE KIND OF
LOCAL WILL WILL GET IT DONE BUT
THESE ARE LOCALLY RUN PROJECTS.
WITH A UV GOT A COULD YOU WOULD
ON DAHLE THOUGH THAT FOR
EXAMPLE THERE ARE- CONVEYANCE
FACILITIES AND OTHER PROJECTS
THAT ALSO NEED TO BE DONE TO
HELP MOVE THE WATER AROUND I
MEAN I GUESS MY I GUESS I'M
HARPING ON THIS BECAUSE THIS
IS. THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE FACING
THE CENTRAL VALLEY- YOU KNOW I
DRIVE THE FIVE NINE NINE I DID
I DID IT YESTERDAY. I MEAN
IT'S- THERE'S DEVASTATION
HAPPENING. ALONG IN THERE IN
THE CENTER VALLEY- TREES ARE
BEING UPROOTED THERE'S JUST
IT'S JUST. IT'S A VERY
DEPRESSING DR WHEN YOU SEE THAT
THAT THE DEVASTATION OF THIS
DROUGHT. AND SO I JUST DON'T
UNDERSTAND IF YOU'RE TELLING ME
THAT IS STILL STICKING POINTS
BETWEEN WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
OVER AROUND. CONVENIENCE AND
WATER STORAGE. THERE HAS TO BE
BECAUSE YOU CLEARLY ARE NOT
INVESTING ANY MONEY IN THIS
BUDGET FOR THAT. THE BUDGET
DOES INCLUDE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR A
CONVEYANCE AND IF I COULD SPEAK
TO A LITTLE BIT TO OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT ALSO THE FOR THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WHICH- YOU KNOW
WE'RE PUTTING A LOT OF FUNDING
INTO SIGMA AND HIS BUDGET.
WHICH WE KNOW YOU KNOW- THAT
CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED BASED
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY- ARE ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED- MORE
FUNDING FOR A WATER RECYCLING
WHICH PROVIDES A GREATER SO A
PLAN RIGHT WILL THE LIABILITY
OF WATER- OPERA GROUNDWATER
CLEANUP WHICH WE KNOW IS ALSO
AN ISSUE ACROSS THE STATE AND
ALSO IN THE- CENTRAL VALLEY
THERE'S- IMMEDIATE ROUTE
SUPPORT THAT WE'RE DOING FOR
THOSE. COUNTIES VISITED ME
PRIMARILY TO THAT ARE IMPACTED
BY DROUGHT WHICH WE KNOW MANY
ARE IN CENTRAL VALLEY AND SO I
WOULD SAY THIS BUDGET AS A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT- SUPPORT- GROWL AND THOSE
COMMUNITIES MOST IN NEED- IN
ADDITION TO COMMANDS WHICH IS
WHAT YOU'RE A TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. SO OKAY IS A I
MEAN. YOU HAVE TO A MILLION
DOLLARS IN COMMANDS I GUESS
THIS IS NOT GOING TO CONVINCE
FOR THE MOMENT. A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THIS YEAR A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AS
PROMISED HOPEFULLY PINKY SWEAR
NEXT YEAR- BUT THERE'S SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS WORTH
OF WORK ON THE COMES A
CONVEYANCE. SO YOU DON'T EVEN
FINISH THE CONVEYANCE WORK. YES
A PART OF THE BILL LANGUAGE OUT
WITH APPROVED IN THE BY JOHN
CONVENIENCE. WILL ALSO SPEAKING
TO A NON STATE COST SHARE AND
ALSO DEPENDING ON THE PROJECTS
SOME OF THEM ARE ARE FEDERALLY
RUN PROJECTS AND SO. ATTENTION
WE HAVING YOU KNOW A FEDERAL
MATCH WHERE THAT WOULD KICK IN
ORDER- LOCAL MATCH. AS THOUGH
YOU KNOW THIS WE BELIEVE THAT A
PARTNERSHIP. WITH THE LOCAL
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BUT YOU KNOW
THE STATE OF PUTTING FORWARD-
SOME SOME BINDING AND HEAR
PENDING ADDITIONAL DISCUSSIONS.
MISTER BERTRAM MASTER YEAH I
APOLOGIZE I I'LL DO THAT ONE
LAST QUESTION AND NOW JUMPED
TO- I'VE I APPRECIATE THE BACK
AND FORTH A LAST QUESTION WHEN
IT COMES. WILL JUMP INTO SB ONE
SEVENTY THREE AND APPRECIATE
THE CHAIRS PATIENTS- JUMPING
THROUGH IS A LOT OF- A LOT OF
CONTENT IN THIS AND THIS AND
THESE FIFTEEN SIXTEEN TO THE
BILLS- IN TERMS OF THE- THE-
THE PROVISIONS TO. ALLOW THE
CITY CALIFORNIA TO GIVE
IDENTICAL IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION TO A UNIVERSITY-
WHEN IT COMES TO RESEARCH
PROJECTS WHEN IT COMES TO- UGH
GUN OWNERSHIP. IS BROKEN IS OUR
PRIVACY CONCERNS HERE AT THAT
THAT THAT. THAT PROFESSORS ARE
COLLEGE STUDENTS WOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO SOMEONE'S
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION. YOUR
RECORD WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- SO TO WORK WITH DOJ
AND THE LEGISLATURE TO WORK
THERE DRESS OF THE PRIVACY
CONCERNS SPECIFICALLY WITHIN
THE TV ALL THE REVISIONS THAT
WOULD REQUIRE. YOU SEE
DANGEROUS AND OTHER RESEARCHERS
THEIR WORK WITH THEIR- A CREDIT
OUR OUR RESEARCH THERE OCT
GOVERNING BODY YOU. YOU FOR- I
RELEASING THIS- BRICK FOR.
WORKING ON HE SEXUALLY PROJECTS
STATE. IT'S SO THERE IS THAT
THERE ARE PRIVACY GUARD RAILS
IS IT IS IT WAS SAYING. THAT'S
CORRECT. IT IN THIS INFORMATION
WILL NOT BE SHARED WITH THE
PUBLIC ONLY FOR RESEARCH THAT
THE INFORMATION OF INDIVIDUAL
OWNERS WOULD NEVER BE FOR THIS
OKAY I THINK THAT'S I THINK
THAT'S THAT THEY THE CONCERNED
THAT THE GRAY AREA THAT WITH
THAT THAT I SEE SO I THANK YOU
FOR THE ANSWERED THANK YOU
CHAIR FOR THE PATIENTS AND I
KNOW I A LOT OF QUESTIONS BUT-
CERTAINLY- THE AT. THESE
TRAILER BILL IS- EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY FOR US
INCENTIVIZE OF THANK YOU. WE
ARE ABSOLUTELY CRUCIAL
QUESTIONS MISTER SMITH.
NOBLENESS THANK YOU. I THINK
THIS IS ALL I'M GOING TO FOLLOW
UP WITH THE GENTLEMAN WITH THE
IN REGARDS OF THE SEQUENCE. FOR
THE- I THINK YOU SAID IT WAS
TWO YEARS TO TOO MUCH TO SPEED
UP THE PROCESS FOR SEQUEL.
NUMBER SORRY ABOUT THE NAME. HI
I WAS ACTUALLY REBEKAH MORIN L-
TURN IT OVER TO HOLD. POLICY
ABOUT ONE YEARBACK IN OUR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YEAH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT IS OUR
UNDERSTANDING. OKAY SO BUT SOME
PROJECTS ARE TAKING TWO MONTHS
SOME PROJECTS ARE STILL TAKING
TWO YEARS IS THERE ANY PROJECTS
WENT FOR STREET THAT. IS TAKING
TOO MUCH DO YOU HAVE A. LISTER
CAN YOU SEND US A LIST OF
FORESTRY PROJECTS THAT I'VE
DONE THROUGH THE SEQUEL. IN TWO
MONTHS- I'M NOT SURE WE HAVE
THAT- IN READILY AVAILABLE AND
I DON'T BELIEVE ANY ARE TAKING
TWO YEARS WE JUST PUSHED OUT
REALLY ACTION DOLLARS. AND ALL
OF THOSE PROJECTS ARE IN
PROCESS OR ON THE GROUND SO
NONE OF THOSE WERE TAKEN. OVER
TWO MONTHS OKAY BUT CAN YOU
SEND MSELF FOR THE WHOLE
COMMITTEE A LIST OF THOSE
PROJECTS THAT ARE GETTING
PUSHED OUT. THROUGH THAT EARLY
ACTION MONEY. SO WE CAN SEE
WHAT IS GOING ON WE CAN TRACK
IT OR YOU CAN LET US KNOW. THIS
PROJECT TOOK FOUR MONTHS TO GET
THE SEQUEL AND IT'S UNDER
CONSTRUCTION AND WE KNOW WHERE
TO FOLLOW THROUGH THAT LINE. AS
PART OF THE TRAILER BILL- WE
ARE. WE ARE COMMITTING TO A
REPORT BY APRIL FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND THAT WILL
CONTAIN ALL THAT INFORMATION.
OKAY AND NOT MOVE MY VICE CHAIR
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE QUESTIONS
IN REGARDS TO THE HYDROELECTRIC
WATER STORAGE. I'D LIKE TO GO
TO THE GENTLEMAN THAT DID THAT
FOR THE PROJECTS. TWO POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS FOR SEVEN
PROJECTS- THE BOND ONE OF
BONDING MONEY. RIGHT NOW WITH
THE PART OF FINANCE YEAH IN
pONE BOND AND THERE WAS TWO
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS-
WHICH IS THERE TO BE
CONDITIONAL WORKS TO SEVEN
PROJECTS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
GOING THROUGH THE APPROVAL
PROCESS IS- BEFORE THE WATER
CONDITIONS YEAH BUT FROM TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN TO NOW IT'S
BEEN SEVEN YEARS HOW LONG DO WE
EXPECTED TO BE FOR. ANY ONE OF
THOSE SEVEN PROJECTS GETTING
DONE HI YOU REFER TO WILL BE A
LOCAL CONTROL THIS IS A STATE
WATER PROJECT MY UNDERSTANDING
THE STATE IS IN CONTROLOF THE
SITES RESERVOIR OR CONVEYANCE
PROJECTS WHAT IS THE HOLD UP
FOR THE STATE NOT TO FINISH
THESE PROJECTS AND HOW MUCH
LONGER DO WE HAVE TO WAIT.
RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA FOR-
WATER CONVEYANCE OF WATER
STORAGE SO I WANT FINANCED INTO
THE QUESTION DID I THANK THE
QUESTIONS TO REMAIN FOCUSED ON
THE BUDGET BILLS THAT IN FRONT
OF US. YOU'RE ASKING ABOUT A
PROP- PROPOSITION BONTA
PREPARATION I GIVE A LOT OF TO
THE VICE CHAIR I THINK HE HAD
NUMEROUS QUESTIONS ON THIS
TOPIC SO AGAIN HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS ON THE BUDGET
BILLS WILL HAVE THIS QUESTION
ANSWERED BUT IF YOU WANT THIS.
OKAY CONVERSATION THAT THEY CAN
FOLLOW UP WITH ME YOU CAN LOOK
AT. IF WE COULD NOT BE ABLE TO.
SO AGAIN. WELL IT'S A QUESTION
AND THEN WE CAN ABSOLUTELY HAVE.
FOLLOW UP DOWN THE ROAD. PLACES
OPENING. YET WHAT TO FOLLOW UP
ON FIVE RATHER OF THE WE HAVE
ANY IDEA. KIND OF TIME LINE ON
ON THAT ONE. WE GET TO YOU
THANK YOU CAN I ASK
TRANSPORTATION QUESTION. YOU
COULD YOU GO THE QUESTION WANT
TO DROP SO YOU CAN ASK ME
QUESTIONS SB SEVENTY AND WE'RE
TO THE TRI. WHAT IS GOING TO
THE COULD PER. IN THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL SINCE THE
APPROPRIATIONS FOR HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY WAS. SEEKING.
FUNDING BUT IT'S NOT FUNDED.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION I
WOULD SAY THE DISCUSSION
SURROUNDING. THE PRIORITY
TRANSPORTATION FOUGHT. PROJECTS
INCLUDING HIGH SPEED RAIL ARE
ONGOING WE EXPECT THERE TO BE
ON FOR THEIR ACTION AS PART OF
EARLY ACTION SOMETIME- IN THE
EARLY NEXT YEAR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THEY CAN JUST
BROKE GROUND ON THIS REVERSING
THE MISTER GALLAGHER. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- I WANT TO FOCUS
MY COMMENTS ON AB ONE FIFTY
FIVE THE RESOURCES BILL- BUT
FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK OUR
CHAIR CHAIR TEEING AND- ARE
BUDGET SUB CHAIR- RICHARD BLOOM
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL-
WHILE I'M EXCITED ON SOME OF
THE ITEMS THAT ARE INCLUDED IN
THIS BILL- I HAVE SERIOUS
CONCERNS ON SOME THAT I FEEL.
ARE ARE AVOIDING- THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE POLICY
PROCESS OF FOR EXAMPLE THE
SEQUEL EXEMPTIONS AND THE FUEL
CELL- NET ENERGY METERING
TARAF- THE SEQUEL EXEMPTION. OF
FOR HABITAT CONSERVE THEIR
THIRTY EXIST A SEQUENCE ACTION
FOR HABITAT CONSERVATION
PROJECTS WITH APPROPRIATE
SAFEGUARDS TO AVOID NEGATIVE
IMPACTS AND THERE'S NO EVIDENCE
THAT SEQUEL HAS BEEN AN
IMPEDIMENT TO WELL PLANNED
LEGITIMATE HABITAT PROJECTS.
THIS EXEMPTION IN THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW LARGE PRIVATE
HABITAT PROJECTS TO AVOID THE
THOROUGH PUBLIC REVIEW OF
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS AS WELL
AS TRIBAL CONSULTATION- WITH
THE FUEL CELL TWO YEAR
EXTENSION. THERE IS IT I THINK
IT UNDERMINES THE PAST PAT
PRACTICE OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE. TO
EVALUATE A MISSION PERFORMANCE
EACH TIME THAT THIS PROGRAM IS
EXTENDED- THERE ARE WELL KNOWN
PROBLEMS WITH VERIFICATION OF
THE UEL CELL EMISSIONS
PERFORMANCE- AND RIGHT NOW THIS
EXTENSION- IS IGNORING A OUR
BASE FAILURE TO COLLECT FUEL
CELL EMISSIONS DATA. AS
PROMISED I HOPE THAT NEXT YEAR
WE CAN WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS-
AND TO WORK THROUGH SOME OF
THESE ISSUES THAT I BELIEVE ARE
ARE PUT IN HERE. TO AVOID OUR
POLICY COMMITTEE PROCESS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR GALLAGHER
THEM GONNA MISTER. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN I WANT TO BEGIN I'M
NOT NOT SURE WHO TO THANK BUT I
DO WANT TO THANK WHOEVER WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR PUTTING IN THE
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION OF THE
WILDFIRE FUNDING- FOR AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE YEARS- WHOEVER
WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT- NOT
SURE WHAT WHO WHO THAT WAS BUT-
IN THE NEGOTIATIONS LOOKS LIKE
THAT'S WHAT CAME OUT HERE
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S SOMETHING
WE'VE BEEN ASKING FOR ALL YEAR-
AND- VERY MUCH SHOULD BE. THE
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY. IN OUR
BUDGET SO THANKFUL FOR THAT
HAVE BEEN INCLUDED- I WANT JUST
GO INTO THE SEQUEL ISSUE AS
WELL- I KIND OF HEARD EARLIER
THE ANSWER TO MR FONG'S
QUESTION THAT SEEK WAS IS
WORKING FINE ON THESE PROJECTS.
THAT SEEMS TO BELIE THE
TESTIMONY THAT WE'VE HEARD- IN
COMMITTEES AND ALSO OUR
WILDFIRE SUMMIT THAT WE HOLD
HELD LAST WEEK WHERE SEVERAL.
IN A FIRE SAFE COUNCILS AND
OTHER GROUPS TESTIFIED THAT
THAT IS ACTUALLY THE- SEQUEL
HAS BEEN AN IMPEDIMENT TO
MOVING PROJECTS QUICKLY. URGENT
PROJECTS STE AND SO I GUESS MY
QUESTION ABOUT THE- F. AND
BUDGET STAFF WANTS TO ANSWER IT.
WHY NOT WHY NOT STREAMLINED
THESE PROJECTS LIKE WE DID THE
THIRTY FIVE PRIORITY PROJECTS.
THIS IS AN UNPRECEDENTED WE'VE
DONE THIS BEFORE WE DID THIRTY
FIVE PROJECTS STREAMLINED
SYKORA. ROSS SAYS WHY NOT DO
THAT AGAIN FOR ADDITIONAL
PRIORITY PROJECTS IN THIS
BUDGET. PLUS GALLAGHER OR-
TURNING TO MY COLLEAGUES I JUST
WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT- IN
MINISTRATION FOUNDED IMPORTANT
TO INCLUDE THAT FIVE YEAR
CONTINUES APPROPRIATIONS FOR A
WILDFIRE- IN IN REGARDS TO SEE
WHAT IT'S LIKE TO TURN THAT
OVER TO YOU- ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES- BELIEVER BACK OF
OUR- I THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ADD TO THAT QUESTION. AS
I SAID BEFORE IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS SEQUEL
PROCESS AND IT IS NOW
STREAMLINED THROUGH THE CAL THE
T. P. OR THE EDUCATION
TREATMENT PROP PROGRAM- IF YOU
ARE STILL HEARING FEEDBACK WE
WOULD LOVE TO HEAR THAT. OKAY
SO YOU'RE SAYING IS IT ART ALL
THESE ARE ALREADY STREAMLINED
THROUGH CALVET IS THAT RIGHT.
YES THAT'S CORRECT D. PROCESS
AT STREAMLINED ALL OF THE
SIGNIFICANT CONSIDERATIONS THAT
ANY FEEL GREAT FIRE PREVENTION
EDUCATION TREATMENT PROGRAM-
PROJECT WOULD. GO THROUGH AND
IT INCORPORATES ALL
CONSIDERATIONS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE. WATER BOARDS AND- THE
AIRPORT- AT THE AIR DISTRICT.
OKAY I WELL I'D BE HAPPY TO
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU GUYS ON
PROJECTS THAT I AM HEARING HAVE
HAD ISSUES- BUT THEN I'LL GO TO
THE NEXT QUESTION FOLLOW UP TO
THAT IS. I THINK WE ALL AGREED
THIS IS URGENT YOU KNOW WHAT
THE FIRES THAT WE'VE HAD. WE
NOW HAVE. A FIRE THE DIXIE FIRE
THAT'S ON THE VERGE OF BEING A
MILLION ACRE. A FIRE- NOTHING
COULD BE MORE URGENT THAN DOING
THESE PROJECTS RIGHT NOW. WHY
NOT AS WE DID IN THIS BUDGET
TRAILER BILL IT JUST EXEMPT
FROM SEQUEL. THESE TYPES OF
PROJECTS AS WE ARE DOING FOR
PROJECTS FOR NATIVEFISH AND
WILDLIFE. THAT'S IN THIS BILL.
SO I'D GO TO THE ADMINISTRATION
OR BUDGET STAFF. MAYBE BOTH. SO
THAT WE DON'T I DON'T HAVE TO
COME REPORT BACK TO YOU LIKE
THOSE PROJECTS WILL BE ABLE TO
JUST MOVE FORWARD UNDER AN
EXEMPTION THE WAY THAT WE HAVE
DONE FOR- A NATIVE FISH
PROJECTS AND WHILE THAT
PROJECTS IN THIS. TRAILER BILL.
PART OF FINANCE I JUST SAY THAT
THEY ARE- DIFFERENT VERY
DIFFERENT TYPE OF PROJECTS- WE
TALK ABOUT LIKE YOU KNOW
HABITAT RESTORATION- OBVIOUSLY
THE PROJECT THAT WE FUND UNDER.
THE WALL FIRE WORTH PACKAGE
HOWEVER YOU KNOW JUST GIVEN
THAT IT IS A PRIORITY- THAT'S
WHY THE CAL THE TPP ISN'T
PLAYING. JUST REMIND HEAD
THERE'S ALSO ADDITIONAL
PROVISION THERE WE HAD IT IN
BUDGET BUILDING WHICH TO-
EXPEDITE THE CONTRACT YOU
PROPERTIES. AS THOUGH YOUR
SPEED EXACTLY A PRIORITY OF THE
ADMINISTRATION AND JUST AS AN
EXAMPLE WITH THE EARLY ACTION-
PACKAGE THAT WAS. APPROVED IN
APRIL- WITHIN THREE MONTHS
BASICALLY 85% OF THOSE DOLLARS
WERE. KIND OF AWARDED AND YOUR
PROJECTS ARE ARE STARTING AND
SO THE RESTORATION IS COMMITTED
TO. CONTINUING TO DO WE CAN'T-
STREAMLINED AND- STREAMLINED
APPROPRIATELY- AND THAT'S WHY
WE DO HAVE A KELLY COULD BE IN
PLACE AND- WE'RE PUTTING IN
ADDITIONAL MEASURES ON HOW TO
CONTACT YOUR POLICIES MAKE
SURE. THAT DOES NOT CREATE
ADDITIONAL BARRIERS. GIVE
BUDGET STAFFER OTHERS HAVE ANY
COMMENT ON THAT. RESPONSE TO
THAT YOU KNOW YOU HE JUST
HEARD- MISS REVERSES COMMENT ON
SEQUEL IN GENERAL SO OBVIOUSLY
SEE ISSUES AREN'T TAKEN
LIGHTLY. THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
HOUSE AND SHE CHAIRS ARE NOT
RESOURCE COMMITTEE WERE THOSE
BILLS WILL GO THROUGH SO IT'S
NOT A- AUTOMATIC- I DON'T I
DON'T THINK THERE'S UNANIMITY
WITHIN THE HOUSE THAT THESE
WOULD ALL BE APPLIED ACROSS THE
BOARD THE ONLY TO BE CURRENT
PLAN ACROSS THE BOARD. OKAY
THAT. YEAH I UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT LIKE FROM BUDGET STAFF WAS
THERE ANYTHING THAT WERE SAYING
HEY WE DON'T WANT TO DO THIS
FOR THOSE PROJECTS AND IT WAS
THAT SOMETHING THAT WAS I THINK
YOU GOT TO COME FROM THE CHAIR
HASN'T. OKAY I'LL TAKE THAT IS
THE ANSWER- HOW WILL THIS YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY AGAIN THESE ARE
PRIORITY PROJECTS WE'RE GETTING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING INTO THEM.
AS THIS INTERACTS WITH- I
BELIEVE IT'S A BILL BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURKE AT AB EIGHT SIXTY.
HOW WILL THAT IMPACT THE
ABILITY TO DO. AS MUCH ACREAGE
AS WE WOULD LIKE TO DO- UNDER
THESE. PROJECTS. I CANNOT TO
OVER TO ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES.
YES WE'RE GONNA PART OF
FINANCE- I'M NOT SURE THE NEXUS
BETWEEN- A BILL THAT YOU'RE
REFERENCING SO WE CAN IT'S
REALLY SPEAK TO THAT. WELL NO
IT IS AS PART OF THE FOREST
MANAGEMENT- KIND OF TASK
REPLIED THAT BROUGHT TOGETHER
YOU KNOW THE SHARED GOAL OF A
FIVE HUNDRED. THOUSAND ACRES
TREATED ANNUALLY BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. SO THAT'S THE YOU
KNOW THE TARGET PUT FORWARD- IN
IN THESE PLANS AS SO YEAH I
THINK IT IS IF COMMITTED WITH
YOU THIS FUNDING TO- YOU KNOW
PLAY ITS SHARE AND THAT THAT
GOAL WHICH INCLUDE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT INCLUDES- STATE
GOVERNMENT INCLUDES- PRIVATE
LANDOWNERS AND SO THAT YOU KNOW
FIVE HUNDRED. ACRES ANNUALLY BY
A HUNDRED THOUSAND EXACTLY BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IS THE
VEHICLE THAT WE PUT OUT. OKAY
I'LL BE MORE SPECIFIC- I
UNDERSTAND THAT'S THE GOAL
THAT'S ACTUALLY AB EIGHT SB SIX
EIGHTY I BELIEVE WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE ANY CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION PROJECTS. TO BE
SUBJECT TO PREVAILING. WAGE AND
OR APPEAL A- HOW IS THAT GOING
TO END. HOW FAR MONEY GO A OF.
ACREAGE BECAUSE RIGHT NOW A LOT
OF THOSE PROJECTS. WHEN YOU DO
THESE FUEL REDUCTION PROJECTS
THEY'RE NOT PREVAILING WAGE.
YEAH I'M NOT TOO SURE HOW WITH
A BIG ON ON THAT BILL AND HOW
THAT WOULD IMPACT- OUR PACKAGE
I'M NOT SURE TAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE. SO YOU
DON'T KNOW IS THAT YOU'RE
SAYING. YEAH I DON'T THINK I
KNOW THE DEADLINE OF TO KNOW
THE NEXUS BETWEEN THAT AND HOW
IT CAN IMPACT- THIS- PROJECT
AND MUCH OF WE HAVE A POSITION
ON ON THAT BILL. OKAY WE WOULD
REALLY BE GOOD TO KNOW THAT
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO BE TAKEN
UP THESE BILLS THIS WEEK. AND
YOU KNOW IF THERE'S GOING TO BE
AN IMPACT ON HOW MANY ACRES WE
CAN TREAT OBVIOUSLY GETTING TO
THE GOAL OF FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND. THAT'S A BIG PROBLEM.
AND SO WE NEED TO HEAR FROM.
THE ADMINISTRATION FROM OTHERS
BUDGET STAFF- AND ANYBODY ELSE
ON THIS CALL THAT HER AUNT
THAT'S- I DON'T KNOW WHO'S ON
HERE BUT CAN ANYBODY ANSWER
THAT QUESTION BECAUSE THIS IS
PRETTY IMPORTANT TO MY
CONSTITUENTS AND I THINK ALL
CALIFORNIANS FOR THAT MATTER.
TO MR GALLAGHER WITH ALL WITH
ALL RESPECT I MEAN WE DO HAVE A
SEPARATE BILL PROCESS ENSURE I
WOULD DIRECT YOU TO- COMMITTEE
BILL ANALYSIS I ASSUME OR HOPE
THAT THOSE ANALYSES WOULD HAVE
COVERED. THOSE ITEMS I DON'T
THINK THAT ANYBODY ON THIS
PARTICULAR CALL IS PREPARED OR
ABLE TO. REALLY ANSWER THAT
SPECIFIC QUESTION ON THE BILL.
HI COULD ANYONE HAVE MISSED NOT
TALKING ABOUT A BILL ABOUT JUST
IN GENERAL LIKE IF WE'RE
SUBJECTING THESE PROJECTS ALL
TO PREVAILING WAGE DOES THAT.
IS I CAN HAVE AN IMPACT ON THE
MONEY AIRS ON TREES. IF YOU IF
YOU GOT THE CIVIC WASHINGTON.
THE ITEM THAT'S FINE BUT I
THINK ASKING PEOPLE TO ANSWER
HYPOTHETICALS IS A DIFFICULT.
QUESTION SOME OTHERS YOU SEE
ALL THIS LEAVE IT AS IT IS
THERE ANYBODY THAT CAN ANSWER
THAT. IF NOT THAT'S FINE BUT IS
THERE SOMEBODY THAT CAN ANSWER
THAT I THINK EVERYONE'S TRY TO
ANSWER TO THE BEST OF THEIR
ABILITY RIGHT NOW. SURE TO KEEP
NOT ONLY HEARD FROM ONE PERSON.
IF YOU WANT TO MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT QUESTION THAT BE GREAT
OTHERWISE WE'LL MOVE ON TO MY
FRIEND YEAH SO WHAT I'M HEARING
IS THAT HEY WE'RE NOT GOING TO
ALLOW PEOPLE TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION THAT'S WHAT I. KNOW
WHAT I'M HEARING IS YOU'RE
ASKING A HYPOTHETICAL QUESTION
AND I'M I'M SAYING THAT IS VERY
DIFFICULT ANSWER HYPOTHETICAL
QUESTIONS THERE IT ISN'T
HYPOTHETICAL BECAUSE WE HAVE A
BILL IN PRINT AB. SIXTY GO TO
THE BILL ANALYSIS FOR. YES IN
THIS BUDGET. THEY INTERRELATE
THEY ABSOLUTELY INTERRELATE.
BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HOW
THIS IS GOING TO IMPACT
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION WHICH
IS IN THIS BUDGET BILL- SO I'M
SURE THERE'S SOMEBODY WHO CAN
ANSWER THE QUESTION BUT THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO ANSWER IT AND
THAT'S FINE. I DON'T THINK IT'S
GOING TO CHANGE YOUR VOTE ON
THAT BILLOR THE BUDGET SO KEEP
GOING. PLEASE. IT'S NOT JUST
FOR ME A MISTER CHAIRMAN IS FOR
THE PUBLIC. AND FOR PEOPLE TO
KNOW HOW THIS IS BEING DONE
THAT. BUT I'VE- I HEAR WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING AND ALL. THE HYPE
ON THE ELECTION PLEASE MOVE ON.
IT'S NOT HYPOTHETICAL BUT-
RIGHT HERE'S ANOTHER NOT
HYPOTHETICAL QUESTION- TWO
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS. IN
THE WATER BOND HAS ACTUALLY
ALREADY BEEN ALLOCATED IT'S
BEEN ALLOCATED SINCE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. WHEN THE WATER
COMMISSION ALLOCATED THOSE
DOLLARS TO THESE DIFFERENT
PROJECTS. THAT'S NOT HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW IN THIS BUDGET. THE
MONEY HAS ALREADY BEEN.
ALLOCATED TO THOSE PROJECTS.
SAID ABOUT BUT YOU HAD ON THE
POINT WHICH IS A LOT OF THESE
PROJECTS A LOT TO GET THROUGH
PERMITTING- SO FOR EXAMPLE
SITES RESERVOIR. HAS BEEN
ALLOCATED A SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT
OF BAHMANI I BELIEVE IT'S A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION- BUT
THEY'RE STILL STUCK IN
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
PERMITTING. SO WHAT IS THE DOES
THE ADMINISTRATION HAVE ANY
PLANS TO HELP STREAMLINE THAT'S
BEEN TWO YEARS NOW. OVER TWO
YEARS- THAT THIS PROJECT HAS
BEEN STUCK IN PERMITTING AND
I'M SURE THERE'S OTHER PROJECT
WITH THE SAME PROBLEM. SO IS
THERE ANY EFFORT ON BEHALF OF
THE ADMINISTRATION TO
STREAMLINE THAT PERMITTING
PROCESS FAST TRACK THAT
PERMITTING PROCESS. GIVEN THAT
THIS IS A VERY URGENT NEED AND
THESE PROJECTS HAVE ALREADY
BEEN IDENTIFIED AS WORTHY OF
FUNDING. YEAH I THINK GOD FOR
DR ARE FAR FINANCE AGAIN I
THINK WE'LL HAVE TO GET BACK TO
YOU WITH- THAT- RESPONSE ON ANY
KIND OF STREAMLINING ON THE
PROP ONE PROJECTS. OKAY NEED
ANYBODY ELSE. OKAY WELL THAT'S
THE END OF MY QUESTIONS I MEAN
I GUESS I'M NOT GONNA GET A LOT
OF ANSWERS TODAY I DO WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
WORK ON GETTING THE CONTINUES
APPROPRIATIONS VERY IMPORTANT.
I WANT TO UNDERSCORE THAT THAT
GREAT APPRECIATION TO GETTING
THAT DONE- THERE ARE OTHER
ISSUES WE GOT TO ADDRESS
HOPEFULLY WE CAN DO THAT. THIS
WEEK OR IN THE NEAR FUTURE
THANK YOU. I'M GONNA GO MISTER
BETTER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF MISTER CHAIR I
WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY THIS
WORKED HARD ON THIS OF THE
CHAIR LEGISLATIVE STAFF
GOVERNOR STAFF APARTMENT
FINANCE EVERYBODY ELSE- IT IT
IT HAS BEEN A HUGE CHALLENGE
AND- IT'S A CHALLENGE AND
BUDGETS ARE TIGHT AS CHALLENGE
BUDGETS ARE ALSO OPEN. IN
SURPLUS AND HAVE THAT OUT THERE
I JUST WANNA VERY QUICKLY POINT
OUT THAT- I PARTICULARLY
APPRECIATE STAFF AND
EVERYBODY'S- OF INSURING THAT
SAY- CONTRACT COUNTIES WERE
ABLE TO RECEIVE THE FUNDING FOR
THE EXTRA FIRE CREWS THAT THEY
HAD REQUESTED. AND POINT OUT
THAT- I HOPE AS WE ARE SPENDING
SIGNIFICANT WILL STICK
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE RESOURCES ON
WILDFIRE PREVENTION THAT WE-
TRY TO MAKE SURE WE LEARN AS
MUCH AS WE CAN THIS YEAR. SO WE
KNOW WHAT ARE THE PRIORITY
EXPENDITURES THAT REALLY HAVE
AN IMPACT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR. THANK YOU MISTER LEE. THANK
YOU ALLEN I THINK THE- PROVIDED
CHAIR I'M SITTING AND ALL THE
STAFF FOR WORKING REALLY
CLOSELY WITH OUR EDUCATIONAL
ADVOCATES I JUST HAVE A COUPLE
CLARIFYING QUESTIONS OF WHAT'S-
ONE SIXTY SEVEN SB ONE SIX
ABOUT THE SCHOOLS I KNOW WE
TOUCHED ON THIS EARLIER BUT
WHEN I JUST MAKE SURE AND
CLARIFY THAT TO SCHOOLS WILL
STILL BE ABLE TO RECEIVE ADA
FOR QUARANTINE STUDENTS
CORRECT. YES. YES PASSED THAT
IS CORRECT DOES THAT INCLUDE
ALSO STUDENTS WHO. ARE EXPOSED
HAVE WITHIN THEIR OWN TIME OF
TESTING AND WAITING FOR THE
RESULTS OF THE TESTING. THOSE
DAYS YEAH FOR ME TURN THAT
QUESTION THE MORE DETAILED
QUESTION OVER TO ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES- EITHER JESSICA
HOLMES OR- PERSONALITY. HI AND
JUST GO HOMES DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I'M STILL I'M SORRY
YOUR QUESTION WAS STUDENTS WHO
ARE NOT IN SCHOOL BECAUSE
THEY'RE WAITING FOR TEST
RESULTS RIGHT IF THEY HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED OR LEARN TO EXPOSURE
BUT THEY HAVE NOT YET BEEN PUT
IN THE FORMAL. QUARANTINE TO
THE DAYS OF WHICH AFTER IS WAIT
FOR RESULTS OR GET TESTED COUNT
TOWARDS ADA. YES YES WE WOULD
CONSIDER THAT BECAUSE THERE
BECAUSE IT'S UNCERTAIN WHAT
THEIR STATUS IS IN THERE
THEY'RE BEING EXCLUDED FROM
SCHOOL BECAUSE THE CONTENT- WE
WOULD AS LONG AS THE- LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCY. WAS
PROVIDING INDEPENDENT STUDY
THEY WOULD BE SUBJECT TO THAT-
THEY WOULD BE THAT THEY WOULD
BE ALLOWED TO RECEIVE A PORTION
THAT. COULD GET THAT'S A GREAT
CONCERN THAT WAS BROUGHT TO ME
BY A LOT OF MY SCHOOL WHERE
MEMBERS PRETENCE I'M GLAD THAT
IS INCLUDED IN THIS FIX AND- I
KNOW THERE'S STILL A LOT OF
CHALLENGES OF THE DELTA PERCENT
DELTA VARIANT AND OTHER PARENTS
PERHAPS FOR ASSIST. AND WE MORE
CHANGES PERHAPS WILL HAVE TO BE
MAKING TO OUR SCHOOLS TO MAKE
SURE WE CAN ADAPT TO IT BUT
THAT'S GOOD TO SEE THAT. AND
THEN I KNOW YOU'LL SUCH FUND IS
A LITTLE BIT BUT- TO COMBAT THE
CUTE SURE- TEACHER SHORTAGE
ESPECIALLY WITH UNDER THE NEW
INDEPENDENT STUDY GUIDELINES
WHAT IS BEING A PORTION THE
BUDGET TO HELP THAT TO MAKE.
SURE THERE'S MORE ITS TEACHINGS
PERSONNEL. SO IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET ACT THAT WAS IT
AND ADOPTED AND ACTED- BACK IN
JULY AND IT WAS JULY SEVENTH-
WE INCLUDED MORE THAN THREE
BILLION DOLLARS. IN NEW. I
RESOURCES INTENDED TO SUPPORT
TEACHER RETENTION AND
RECRUITMENT- IT WENT TO QUITE A
FEW DIFFERENT- INITIATIVES BUT-
THEY WERE SOME OF THE MORE
INCLUDING AND IT AND IT
REPAYMENT OF. STUDENT LOANS OR
SCHOLARSHIPS ESSENTIALLY- TO
TEACHERS WHO TAUGHT IN HIGH
NEED AREAS I'M FOR A PERIOD OF
TIME AND WE ALSO HAD FUNDS
GOING TOWARDS A SIGNIFICANT
FUNDS GOING TOWARDS TEACHER
TRAINING- SO IT SAID THERE WERE
THERE WAS QUITE A BIT OF MONEY
AND IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET ACT THAT WAS ADOPTED
BACK IN JULY. AND TO ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES SO THREE BILLION
IS ALLOCATED DO YOU KNOW HOW
MUCH OF IT WAS ALREADY EXPENDED.
EXPENDED FROM WHAT WAS ENACTED
IN JULY- I'LL- NEVER AND PASS
ON. NO NO IT'S IT I DON'T KNOW
THE ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION I
WOULD ASSUME PROBABLY NOT NOT A
LOT OF IT- BUT AND BUT I KNOW
THAT THERE IS QUITE A BIT OF
URGENCY TO GET THOSE FUNDS OUT
AND TO AND TO GET THOSE
PROCESSES MOVING I THINK THE
OTHER THING. THAT WE'RE REALLY
TRYING HARD TO DO IS TO
PROVIDE- AT THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ALSO
INTO IT OUR COLLEAGUES OVER THE
STATE BOARD I'M INFORMATION TO
ELEAZAR ON PROGRAMS THAT ARE
ALREADY AVAILABLE HAVE BEEN AND
HAVE BEEN AVAILABLE- THAT THEY
CAN BE UTILIZING RIGHT NOW IN
ORDER TO HELP THEM AND IT MAY
NOT BE NECESSARILY IN THE IN
THE IN THE VERY SHORT TERM BUT
BUT IN THE MIDDLE AND LONG TERM
TO HELP BUILD THEIR CAPACITY
OUT. THERE'S ALSO SOME RECENT
CHANGES AROUND THINGS LIKE-
EXTENDING THE C. BEST A WAIVER
FOR. EACH TYPE OF EDUCATIONAL
STAFF THAT- THAT STATE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WHEN HIGHER THAT
HAPPENED BACK IN THE JULY
BUDGET AS WELL SO THERE ARE
THERE ARE MANY SORT OF HORT
TERM AND MIDDLE LONG TERM
THINGS THAT FOLKS ARE WORKING
ON BEYOND JUST THE FUNDING TO
HELP ADDRESS SOME OF THESE
NEEDS AND CONCERNS. GREAT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU EIGHT ONE IS THERE BY
ALSO THINKING THE CHAIR AND ALL
THE STUFF IS BEEN WORKING-
TEARS THE ALL YEAR ON THIS
BUDGET I WAS THE ONE I THINK
THE ATTENTION AROUND SAFE
DRINKING WATER IN DROUGHT
RESILIENCE- AND YOUR BILLION
DOLLARS THAT IS BEING
IMPLEMENTED THERE AS WE'RE
SEEING THEIR HISTORIC DROUGHT
ACROSS THE STATE AGAIN. I
WANTED THIS ALLOCATION INCLUDES
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS- TO
ADDRESS THE PEAPOD'S ISSUES.
ANOTHER AT LEAST THREE HUNDRED
WELL THAT HAVE BEEN I
DISCONNECTED BECAUSE OF THE
CONTAMINATION OF PEAPOD'S WHICH
MEANS WE'RE RELYING ON MORE
IMPORTED WATER. IN BECOMING
LESS DROUGHT RESILIENT IN
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE AND SO I
DO APPRECIATE. THAT INVESTMENT
ACT. EARLY ON IN IN THIS CRISIS
THAT WE'RE SEEING- BUT IT WOULD
JUST COME FOR THE CITY HUNTER
WELLS THIS IS ABOUT A FIFTH OF.
OF THE MONEY THAT WE'RE
PROBABLY GONNA NEED JUST TO
START THE PROCESS- AND SO I DO
HOPE THAT IN THE FUTURE WE
CONTINUE TO TRACK THIS- AND WE
CONTINUE TO. HELP COMMUNITIES
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES CAN
AFFORD TO DO THAT THEMSELVES TO
THE NOT BECAUSE THE PROVINCE
ITSELF AND SO. JUST I AM
APPRECIATED THAT WE ARE TAKING
AN IMPORTANT STEP IN
ACKNOWLEDGING THE NEED OUT
THERE- AND BEING A LEADER FOR A
FOR THE STATE IN THIS ISSUE
AND- LOOK FORWARD TO ADDITIONAL
WORKED ON THE RIGHT ON THIS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANKS FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THE THAT P.
FAST ISSUE MR MCCARTY. YES YOU
I JUST WANTED TO TOUCH BASES ON
BASE- THE EDUCATION CLEAN UP
BILLS HEARING I KNOW. MISTER
VICE CHAIR MENTIONED THAT WE
HAVE MULTIPLE. BUDGET BILL
JUNIORS BUT I THINK THAT'S
BEING RESPONSIBLE BECAUSE WE'RE
IN A GLOBAL PANDEMIC. IT'S
REALLY HARD PUTTING KIDDING
KIDS BACK TO SCHOOL. I THINK
LOUD AND CLEAR HERE LAST YEAR
WE REALIZE THAT ZOOM SCHOOL.
DID NOT WORK ESPECIALLY FOR SO
MANY COMMUNITIES. WHO DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY. STAY
AT HOME PARENTS WHO CAN STAY ON
TOP OF THEIR KIDS. THE THIS IS
LEARNING LOS IT'S YOU KNOW.
NINE LOS BECAUSE THAT LEARNING
NEVER HAPPEN THE FIRST PLACE
AND SO. OUR DEFAULT IS GOING
BACK TO SCHOOL AND I THINK
THAT- THE CLARIFICATIONS HERE
ON INDEPENDENT STUDY. ARE ARE
APPROPRIATE I KNOW SOMEONE US
TO GREEN LIGHT GOING BACK. TO
FULL VIRTUAL AND ZOOM SCHOOL
AND WE'RE NOT DOING THAT. I
THINK WORSE WE'RE STAYING THE
COURSE HERE WE ARE CLARIFYING.
THAT EDA CAN AND SHALL BE
RECEIVED AS MR LEE NOTED WHEN
STUDENTS ARE ON QUARANTINE. OR
IN LIMBO. OF THAT. OR THE
PARENTS JUST AREN'T COMFORTABLE
IF THEY WANT THEIR KIDS TO GO.
AND DO SOME INDEPENDENT STUDY-
BASICALLY AND I TALKED TO- MR
ARAMBULA TODAY AND FRESNO ONE
OF MY DISTRICT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO IT'S ABOUT 5% OF THE
POPULATION OF THE PARENTS.
DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN THAT MEANS 95%
WANT TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL AND
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE WE ARE
FOCUSING ON- AND THERE'S A LOT
OF. UNCERTAINTY THE DELTA
VARIANT TO WHAT HELPS PEOPLE
WITH COMMON WHO ARE VACCINATED.
I WENT THROUGH THAT TO MYSELF I
WAS ACTUALLY IN IRAQ OF ITSELF.
IT CAN'T HAPPEN- BUT WE JUST
HAVE TO ADAPT AND KEEP MOVING.
IF THERE'S SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENS I KNOW PEOPLE ARE
SAYING. WE SHOULD HAVE A PLAN
BE ABLE SOMETHING HAPPENS IN
THE FALL WITH THERE'S LIKE A
CRAZY NOTE. VERY EXPLOSION WE
CAN COME BACK ADDRESS THIS IN A
SPECIAL SESSION- FOR SOMETHING
ELSE BUT RIGHT NOW. WE ARE
1100% AT THE IN REOPENING OUR
SCHOOLS- AND I DO NOT THE MIST
MISTER BENNETT DID DID BRING UP
A GOOD POINT ABOUT. THE LACK OF
SUBSTITUTES ESPECIALLY WITH
TEACHERS STAYING OUT AND
POTENTIALLY- TESTING POSITIVE.
WEEK WE HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
SOME FLEXIBILITY HERE AS FAR AS
EXTENSION FOR THAT- I THINK NOT
ENOUGH WE TRY TO NEGOTIATE WITH
ALL PARTIES WEEK WE COULDN'T
COME UP TO. I THINK FURTHER
EXPANDING OPTIONS FOR
SUBSTITUTES BUT- BUT BUT BY AND
LARGE I THINK THIS IS A- BIG
IMPORTANT PRUDENT OVER WHAT WE
JUST PASSED A FEW. WEEKS AGO
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY WE'RE
LISTENING TO PEOPLE AROUND THE
STATE TALKING ABOUT WAS NEEDED
TO MAKE SURE. THAT OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM WORKS DURING
THIS CALL THE CRIME ITSELF
THANK YOU THANKS TO OUR OUR
STAFFING DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
FOR WORKING ON THIS LAST FEW
WEEKS AS WELL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. OKAY SEE NOW
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO A
PUBLIC COMMENT WITH ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT IN THE- BROOM I SEE
SOMEBODY WALKING AND THEN IF
TOP WRITER COULD GIVE PUBLIC
COMMENT CUED UP PLEASE COME
FORWARD AND- SPEAK. TO THE
OPERATOR KEPT OUR PUBLIC COMING
QUEUED UP ON THE FOUR ON THE
PHONE WOULD APPRECIATE IT THANK
YOU. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE
SHOULD MAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ALEX TOWARDS WITH STRATEGIES
THREE SIXTY HERE OFFER COMMENTS
ON BEHALF OF A COUPLE CLIENTS
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
FOREST FOUNDATION ORGANIZATION
THAT REPRESENTS A CALIFORNIA'S-
FAMILY OWNED FOREST LANDS YEAH
THEY'VE HEARD PLANTS MAKE UP
20% OF CALIFORNIA'S FORESTS. WE
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR THE
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION FROM
THE G. IRA FUND FOR WILDFIRE
AND FOREST PREVENTION- ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
INDEPENDENT VENUE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WE ALSO WANT TO
THANK SAY THANK YOU. FOR THE
WORK DONE- FOR THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE PROGRAM IS
ALSO SOME OF THE TECHNICAL
CHANGES REALLY APPRECIATIVE OF
YOUR STAFF HEARING FEEDBACK
FROM OVER CALIFORNIA'S FOUR
HUNDRED OVER OVER FOUR HUNDRED
INDEPENDENTLY OWNED VENUES. AND
PROMOTERS REALLY APPRECIATE THE
HELP IN HELPING GET A PROGRAM
OFF THE GROUND THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SURE MEMBERS CHRIS
BOLLINGER ON BEHALF OF THE
SACRAMENTO ASIAN PACIFIC
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN THE
PROSPERITY PARTNERSHIP. OUR
COALITION INCLUDES GREATER
SACRAMENTO ECONOMIC COUNCIL
SACRAMENTO METROPOLITAN CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE SEGMENT ASIAN
PACIFIC CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
SACRAMENTO AREA COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS AND VALLEY VISION.
WE ARE HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
ONE SIXTY TWO WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE ADMINISTRATION
LEGISLATURE FOR ALL YOUR GOOD
WORK ON THE COMMUNITY ECONOMIC
RESILIENCE FUND. WE ESPECIALLY
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT AB ONE SIXTY
TWOS EMPHASIS ON EQUITY AND
INCLUSIVENESS. THE GREATER
SACRAMENTO REGION IS NOW
MAJORITY MINORITY WITH A
QUARTER OF OUR BUSINESS OWNERS
BEING BLACK. INDIGENOUS AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR WE THINK SURF
IS THE PERFECT TOOL TO HELP
ACCOMPLISH THE GOAL OF BUILDING
AN EQUITABLE. AND SUSTAINABLE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY FROM THE
IMPACTS TO COVER NINETEEN.
WE'RE EXCITED FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CEMENT OUR
REGION'S OBLIGATION. HAS THIS
ENTERS- PLANNING AND GRANT
MAKING FACES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. FORWARD OPERATING THERE
IS GOOD APPREHENSION. YES SIR
I'M HERE WE CURRENTLY HAVE
TWENTY EIGHT IN Q. FOR- FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT WE'LL START WITH
LINE NUMBER THIRTY NINE LINE
THIRTY NINE LINE IS NOW OPEN.
FIVE GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
NUMBER CON ABOUT ON BEHALF THE
DISTRICT HOSPITAL LEADERSHIP
FORUM. WE WISH TO THANK THAT
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND-
ESPECIALLY DOCTOR WOULD FOR.
AND COULDN'T BE DIFFICULT BUT-
LEADERSHIP MONNING BRIDGE LOCAL
COUNSEL IN AB AND SB ONE
SEVENTY AND. WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NINE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON NATALIE
MATH NUMBER OF CLIENTS
INCLUDING COMMITTEE NATURE
CONNECTION IN NATURE FOR ALL- I
JUST WANTED THE TIME TO POINT
OUT HOW IMPORTANT THE
CONSERVANCY AREN'T THEY ARE
CRITICAL ROLE I'M A CRITICAL
PARTNER IN CARRYING OUT ON THE
RESILIENCE PROJECTS ON THE
GROUND. SO I WANT TO EXPRESS
OUR APPRECIATION FOR THE DIRECT
FUNDING FOR SOME OF THE
CONSERVATIVES IN THE BUDGET
THIS YEAR- BUT ALSO HOPE TO SEE
GREATER LEVELS OF FUNDING FOR
THE SEVENTIES. AND FUTURE
BUDGET YEARS. THANK YOU. LINE
SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I CAN'T REMEMBER A CRIPPLE CAL
ON BEHALF OF TOPWEIGHT COMPANY
PRODUCTS HERE SHOULD COUNCIL
BALI POSITION NORTH AMERICA ALL
ONE POINT EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY
DIFFICULT ALLOCATION TO ALLOW
COUNTY PACKAGE AS WELL AS THE
ONE THIRTY MILLION TWENTY SB
THIRTY THREE AGAIN AGENCY
APPRECIATE STAFF WORK ON IT'S A
LONG WAY AND LAND AND- LIKE
HOUSEKEEPER SECURING FUNDING.
ALSO ON BEHALF THAT COUNTY
BEFORE AND SAN JOAQUIN YOUR
SUPPORT SECTION TWENTY SIX OF
EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY. WHAT ARE
YOU EXTENSION FOR THE COMMUTER
WITH INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT
PROGRAM JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY THREE WE APPRECIATE THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE STAFF WORK. ON
ITSELF THANK YOU. TWENTY YEAR
LATER. MISTER TURN MEMBERS
CHRISTOPHER- OF HEALTH FOR CAL
POOREST OF THE NINE EIGHTY
EIGHT MILLION TO THE PREVENTION
AND RISK PACKAGE- THE
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION
TOWARDS THE FOREST IT HE WE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION- TO ENSURE THAT
THE STATE MAINTAINS THE
NECESSARY INVESTMENTS. SO THAT
THE STATE FOREST RESILIENCY
GOALS CAN BE ACHIEVED THANK YOU.
ONE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU CHAIR KING IN
NUMBERS EVEN BUYERS ON BEHALF
OF MADONSELA REGIONAL OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT STATE THE
REDWOODS LEAGUE FORBEARANCE ON
LAND TRUST OF SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
ON THE CALIFORNIA HABITAT
CONSERVATION PLAN COALITION. WE
ARE EXTREMELY GRATEFUL FOR THE
SEQUEL EXEMPTION IN SB ONE FIVE
FIVE FOUR PROJECTS THAT PROMOTE
WILDLIFE AND HABITAT. THIS WILL
HELP MEET OUR COMMON GOAL TO
STREAMLINE PROJECTS TO REACH
THE STATE'S CLIMATE AND
CONSERVATION GOALS. WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE STATE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY SAN FRANCISCO BAY
PROGRAM WHICH WILL SUPPORT OUR
PROJECTS THROUGHOUT THE BAY
AREA. UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE
DISAPPOINTED IN THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING FOR THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD AND THAT'S
THE ONE SEVENTY. GIVEN THE LACK
OF NEW BOND FUNDING MANY OF
THEIR PROGRAMS ARE ALMOST
ENTIRELY DEPLETED. AND FINALLY
WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE GUIDING
LANGUAGE IN SB ONE FIVE FIVE
I'M A PRIORITIES IN THE FUTURE
BUDGET YEARS. WHO WORRIED THAT
THERE ISN'T A CALL OUT FOR W.
C. B. WHICH IS AN ESSENTIAL
PARTNER AND CLIMATE RESILIENCE
AND CONSERVATION ROJECT. WZVN
ARE ORGANIZATIONS NEED TO KNOW
WHAT TO EXPECT AND FUTURE
BUDGET YEARS IN ORDER TO PLAN.
AND SCHEDULE PROJECTS THANK YOU.
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS
JENNIFER PHANG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MUSEUMS ALONG WITH A HUNDRED
CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS AND
TWENTY TWO LEGISLATORS CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT FUNDING TO PROTECT
CULTURAL AND HISTORICAL ASSETS
FROM CLIMATE IMPACTS AND FOR
CLIMATE CHANGE EDUCATION BY
MUSEUMS SCIENCE CENTER IS THE
TO THE KOREANS AND THE LIKE. ON
BEHALF OF THE MOUNTAIN LION
FOUNDATION AND NATIONAL
WILDLIFE FEDERATION WE DO
APPRECIATE GREATLY THE TRAINER
TO FIFTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
IN EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY OVER THE
NEXT THREE YEARS TO THE
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD FOR
PROJECTS THAT INCLUDE WILDLIFE
CROSSINGS IN CONNECTIVITY. THE
FALCONS OF THE SB ZERO SAN
DIEGO HUMANE SOCIETY AND BEST
FRIENDS ANIMAL SOCIETY ARE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THE APPROPRIATION
OF FUNDS TO INITIATE
MODERNIZATION CALIFORNIA'S
ANIMAL BLOOD BANKING INDUSTRY
AND LASTLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FISH AND GAME MORE
THAN SUPERVISORS AND MANAGERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
LABAIK OFFICERS FOUNDATION.
THANK YOU FOR THE APPROPRIATION
TO CREATE TWENTY NINE
ADDITIONAL P. RISE TO HELP
ADDRESS ISSUES RELATED TO
CANNABIS AND WE ARE GRATEFUL TO
THE FACTORY STAFF AND SHARED TO
THE SPEAKER STAFF. FOR ALL
THEIR HARD WORK AND LEADERSHIP.
MY SIXTY FOUR YEAR LIGHTED UP.
THANK YOU IN BREAKING WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT IN SUPPORT
OF SB ONE SEVENTY AND REALLY
APPRECIATE THE INCLUSION OF THE
BIRDS ON FUNDS FOR HEALTH CARE
DISTRICT THANK YOU. ONE
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS ALEXA CHáVEZ
WITH CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE
WERE CALLING TO EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE CAL
RECYCLE ALLOCATIONS
SPECIFICALLY THE FUNDING FOR
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE THIS
MONEY WILL GO A LONG WAY
TOWARDS GETTING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ON TRACK TO MEET
THE REQUIREMENTS OF THIS
LANDMARK CLIMATE BILL AHEAD OF
THE JANUARY FIRST.
IMPLEMENTATION DEADLINE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE AN ONGOING DEDICATION TO
SUPPORTING WASTE REDUCION IN
CRIME ACTION. ONE THIRTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE THIRTY
ONE IS THAT ME. IT IS- IT IT
MIGHT ON I'M I MEAN I IN THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE I'M IN THE RIGHT
PLACE BECAUSE THE PHONES DON'T
ALWAYS WORK CAN I BE HEARD IN
COMMITTEE. AFTER NUMBER HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME IN THE RIGHT
PLACE IS THIS THE CALIFORNIA
ASSEMBLY THE BUDGET HEARING IF
YOU COULD GO TO CONTINUE THE
PROGRESS. A LOT OF. I'M HERE.
YOU'RE THERE- EXCELLENT BE
FILLED SAYING YES- WELL I JUST.
I THINK I THINK IT'S REALLY
UNFORTUNATE THAT YOU DIDN'T
UPDATE THE WEBSITE UNTIL THIS
MORNING BECAUSE CALIFORNIANS
DESERVE TO HAVE ACCESS TO
INFORMATION AND IT WAS THE JULY
FIFTEENTH ONE THAT WAS DOWN OFF
THE SEPTEMBER SEVENTH ONE
PUBLIC MOURNING AND YOU KNOW I
SEEM TO RECALL FROM LIKE MIDDLE
SCHOOL SOMETHING CALLED THE
BROWN ACT THAT YOU GUYS HAVE TO
LIKE PUT INFORMATION OUT THERE.
FOR THE PUBLIC TO SEE AND JUST
IN TERMS OF BACK I JUST THINK
THE WAY THAT- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER WAS TREATED BY THE
CHECKOUT WAS REALLY
INAPPROPRIATE BECAUSE PEOPLE
LIKE ME WHO HAVE BEEN DISPLACED
BY FIRES DON'T SEE THE MILLION.
ACRES THAT HAVE BEEN BURNED BY
THE DIXIE AS HYPOTHETICAL SHARE
KING THAT'S A REAL RUNNING FROM
FLAMES ISRAEL I HAVE BEEN IN
THAT COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM
WITH MY CHILDREN MY CHILDREN
GIVING TESTIMONY IN WILDFIRE
HEARINGS SO IT'S NOT
HYPOTHETICAL THEY ARE INTER
RELATED AND THE FACT THAT YOU
WOULD TREAT A COLLEAGUE THAT
WAIT ON RECORD IS REALLY
REPREHENSIBLE TO ME BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT I'VE COME TO THIS
CONCLUSION. THAT GOVERNMENT IS
A GANG IT HAS NO LEGITIMATE
AUTHORITY ESPECIALLY IF IT'S
BEING WON BY A SUPERMAJORITY
HOW ARE YOU SEE VOTING AS AN
ACT OF SELF DEFENSE NOT
LEGITIMIZING SOMETHING THAT IS
INHERENTLY ILLEGITIMATE THE
GANG USED SUPERMAJORITY COMMON
COULD NOT HEAR. WHAT PEOPLE
THINK OF IT YOUR- LIKE TO TWO
YEAR AND NOW ALL. MEMBERS CAN
GIVE EACH FAMILY HALF OF TECHNO.
IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE FIVE
SCIENCE SPECIFICALLY THE
EXTENSION OF THE FUEL CELL IN
AN ENGINEERING THANK YOU. LINE
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS KAREN LAYING
REPRESENTING ALL FIVE OF THE
DELTA COUNTY SACRAMENTO SOLANO
SAN JOAQUIN YELLOW AND CONTRA
COSTA IN OPPOSITION TO THE
PROVISION OF AB ONE FIVE FIVE
THAT INCLUDES FIFTY QUID
EXEMPTION FOR HABITAT
RESTORATION PROJECT. WAT WE DO
RECOGNIZE THERE'S A PROHIBITION
ON THE EXEMPTION APPLYING TO
CONSTRUCTION THERE'S STILL A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF CONFINED
LANE WITH THE COUNTY IS RELATED
TO LOCAL INVOLVEMENT AND NO
LIMITATION ON THE SIZE OF THE
PROJECT AND HOW CRITICAL IT IS
THE LOCAL AGENCIES BE PART OF
THE PROCESS AND FOR THAT REASON
THEY'RE ASKING FOR THAT VERSION
OF THE BILL TO BE REMOVED OR
YOUR NO VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU. LANE SIXTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BURKE
THEY'RE REALLY ON BEHALF OF UWS
THE CORE OF ATSC ONE THIRTY TWO
WE APPRECIATE THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE LEGISLATURE
DEPARTMENTS LIMITATION FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THE ICE THE
CAREER PATHWAY LANGUAGE.
TRAINING COURSE MONEY
INCENTIVES WILL GREATLY HELP
RETAINER KERR I TYPICAL
PROVIDERS INCREASE THE QUALITY
OF CARE FOR CONSUMERS. THINKING
YEARS BACK FOR ALL YOUR WORK.
LINE EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
THE POLITICAL ANALYST VIA AND
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL TO PROVIDE
COMMENTS IN ASKING ONE SEVENTY
IN SB FIVE FIVE. BEGIN WITH
SUPPORT EXPANSION OF THE WATER
SHUTOFF MORATORIUM HOWEVER WE
HAVE TO UPDATE THE EXTENDED AT
LEAST UNTIL JANUARY THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO
CORRESPOND WITH THE DATE OF. IN
THE WATER GETS RELIEF PROGRAM
SECOND WE ALSO SUPPORT OF THE
ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION
ALLOCATION FORCING MY
IMPLEMENTATION BUT PRETTY QUICK
WHEN JEWS FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
MAY REVISE RIGHT YET ADDED TO
CREATE A 30% OF BY PARTICULAR
PROJECT AND ARGUMENT THAT ASIDE
FOR PROJECTS THAT BENEFIT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
WE'RE GLAD TO SEE SOME
PREFERENCE TO REDUCE DDR DP AND
REPORTING ON THE LIVESTOCK
METHANE REDUCTION CATEGORY
CATALYST FUND SO WE NEED TO
FULLY STOP SUPPORTING THERE'S A
JESTER'S AND FOCUS ON DIRECTLY
REDUCING METHANE. IN THE FIRST
PLACE LASTLY SUPPORT THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE CENTERS PROGRAM SB
ONE FIVE FIVE SO WE URGE YOU
THINK TO INVEST MUCH MORE THAN
A HUNDRED MILLION THE HUNDRED
MILLION ALLOCATED OVER THE NEXT
TWO YEARS FOR THIS PROGRAM THE
BENEFIT OF THE CRYPTO COMMUNITY
CENTERS TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
HELLO IN ORDER TO INCREASE THE
RESILIENCE OF COMMUNITY DOES
SUCH AN HONORABLE PRIVATE
MOMENT LIKE THIS ONE THE STATE
SHOULD ALLOCATE ON ON YOUR
BILLION OVER THE NEXT. TWO
YEARS TO COMMITTEE RECENTLY
CENTERS THANK YOU. LIKE FIFTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY- CAVALRYMAN
ON OF THE STATE AT OF COUNTIES
REPRESENTING ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES WE WOULD LIKE TO
BRIEFLY REGISTER SUPPORT FOR
THREE HIGH PRIORITY ITEMS. AN
EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY WE SUPPORT
THE ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION
FOR ORGANIC WASTE
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPLEMENTATION
IN PARTICULAR WERE VERY PLEASED
WITH THE FIFTEEN MILLION FROM
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS SACRAMENTO
RIGHT ORGANICALLY TO VERSION
REGULATIONS. FOR EIGHTY ONE
THIRTY FIVE WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION FOR CALIFORNIA
FOR HEALTHY FOREST FIRE
PREVENTION PROGRAM. THE FUNDING
IS CRITICALLY NECESSARY FOR
ONGOING ALL TYPES OF FIRE
PREVENTION PROJECT. AND FINALLY
SEPARATELY ON A. B. AND THAT'S
THE ONE SEVENTY SEVEN. THE
STOCK ALONG WITH OUR COLLEAGUES
WHAT THE URBAN AND RURAL COUNTY
ASSOCIATIONS WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE ALL THE HARD WORK
THAT WENT INTO LANDING. AN
ADDITIONALROUND OF CRIMINAL
JUSTICE BE REPEALED THIS YEAR
WE BELIEVE THE S. B. N. EIGHTY
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN REPRESENTS A
OF REASONABLE LANDING SPOT. AND
APPRECIATE THE ON GOING COUNTY
REVENUE. BACK SO THAT IS
INCLUDED THANK YOU. ONE TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BURKE
JOHN WHEN YOU'RE ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA. CARTER SCHOOLS-
EXPRESS OUR CONCERN WITH THAT
YOU WANT THE SEVEN I DID A BIT
IN A PORT IN CHARTER SCHOOL
FUNDING PROTECTION THAT IS-
INCLUDED IN SB ONE SIXTY SEVEN
COMPANION TRAILER BILL IN THE
SENATE AB ONE SIXTY SEVEN. THE
PROVISION OMITTED FROM SB ONE
SIXTY SEVEN INCLUDED IN SECTION
THIRTY OF AB ONE SIXTY SEVEN
THEN SHARED THE SITE BASED
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND THEIR
STUDENTS HAVE THE SAME ACCESS
AND RIGHTS AS ALL OTHER
STUDENTS WHILE THE DOCTOR VERY
CONTINUE TO DISRUPT. IN PERSON
LEARNING SPECIFICALLY THE
PROVISION SIMPLY CLARIFIES THAT
UP OVER 20% OF STUDENTS ARE
TEMPORARILY MOVED TO
INDEPENDENT STUDY DUE TO A COLD
OUTBREAK IT WILL NOT RECLASSIFY
THE SCHOOL THE NON CLASSROOM
BASED SCHOOL WHICH WOULD PUT
CRITICAL FUNDING IN JEOPARDY WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE THE ASSEMBLY
EITHER A MAN SB ONE SIXTY SEVEN
TO INCLUDE THIS PROVISION. OR
REJECT SB ONE SIXTY SEVEN AND
MOVE AB. ONE SIXTY SEVEN PORT
AS THE VEHICLE THANK YOU. RIGHT
WILL NOT READ OUT TODAY FOR
SAKE DIRECTLY. CHECK IN ANY YES
PLEASE THANK YOU. SORRY ABOUT
THAT THANK YOU- IN PARTICULAR
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
INCLUSION OF AB S. B. ONE
SEVENTY OF A HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION FROM THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND FOR WASTE
REDUCTION AND MANAGEMENT
INCLUDING THE SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
IMPLEMENT THE CARROTS LIKE
LET'S BE THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
ORGANIC WASTE DIVERSION
REGULATIONS A SEVENTY MILLION
PARK ANTIQUATED INFRASTRUCTURE
WE'RE PLEASED TO SEE THE
INCLUSION OF BOTH TYPES OF
GRANT FUNDING FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE THESE FUNDS WILL
HELP LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO GET
THEIR SB THIRTEEN THREE
PROGRAMS UP AND RUNNING.
CALPURNIUS METHANE EMISSIONS
AND FOOD WASTE IN OUR CITIES
WANT TO THANK YOU I CENTER
SKINNER WHITE HOUSE KIAN
LAYERED AND ALL THE STAFF FOR
THE HARD WORK TO SECURE THIS
FUNDING AND ARE GRATEFUL FOR
THIS DOWN PAYMENT FROM THE
STATE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING FUTURE DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
HELP CALIFORNIA CITIES. COMMENT
THIS IMPORTANT PROGRAM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. LINE EIGHTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. Y.
EIGHT SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOUR LINE IS NEEDED WERE UNABLE
TO HEAR YOU. WILL MOVE ON TO MY
NUMBER THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. THIS IS YOUR MEMBERS
THIS IS OFTEN ALONG THE BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMPOST
COALITION WOULD LIKE TO EXTEND
A STRONG SUPPORT FOR BOTH IS
BEAST ONE SEVENTY. ESPECIALLY
SECTION EIGHTY FIVE WHERE YOU
CLARIFY THE ELIGIBILITY OF
COMPOSTING AT STATION SOURCES
FOR THE FUNDING. AND UNDER SB
ONE FIFTY FIVE THE RESOURCES
BONTA RESOURCES MEASURE IN
PARTICULARLY- THE CALORIE CYCLE
AND SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE
FUNDING WE IN STRONG SUPPORTER
THANK YOU. WHY NUMBER TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DRAGANA
MORALIS AND I AM CALLING ON
BEHALF OF LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
FIRST WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION FOR KNOWLEDGE IN
THE NEED FOR MORE RESEARCH
OVERSIGHT TO JUSTIFY. ANY
CONTINUE TAXPAYER SUBSIDIES FOR
GARY DIED GESTURES WE HOPE
OTHER STATE AGENCIES LIKE CARP
C. C. C. P. C. TO NAME A FEW
WILL ALSO HEAR YOUR- ARE YEARS
LONG CONCERNED ABOUT THE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF LARGE SCALE
FACTORY THEORY OF OPERATIONS ON
COMMUNITIES AND THE FACT THAT
THEY TESTERS ARE ONLY
EXACERBATING THOSE. TAKEN AT
THE ONE FIFTY FIVE TAKES A GOOD
FIRST STEP AND COLLEEN FOR IN
DEPTH ANALYSIS AS TO THE TRUE
COSTS AND BENEFITS ASSOCIATED
WITH TERRY DI TESTERS WE WANT
TO URGE THAT RESEARCH BE
CONDUCTED BY SOMEONE WHO DOES
NOT HAVE INDUSTRY TIES.
INCREASE KNOWLEDGE WILL
INCREASE THE COLLECTIVE
UNDERSTANDING THAT FACTORY
FARMED GAS IS NOT A CLIMATE
SOLUTION WE ALSO COMMEND SB
FIFTY ONE FIFTY FIVE EXCLUSION
OF PROJECTS TO PRODUCE BIOGAS
BOARD OFF FARM USE FROM BEING
ELIGIBLE FOR CRIME THE CATALYST
FUNDING LAST ORGANIZATIONS AND
THE COMMUNITY MEMBERS WE
REPRESENT STRONGLY OPPOSE ANY
ADDITIONAL TAXPAYER RATEPAYER
FUNDING FOR DAIRY DIGESTERS
INCLUDING THE PROPOSED FORTY
EIGHT MILLION INSURANCE GENERAL
FUND. FOR LIVESTOCK METHANE
REDUCTION FOR FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE SHOWN
IN THE RESOURCES PACKAGE
SPREADSHEET THAT'S. BEEN
CIRCULATED THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY
FIVE YOUR LONG IS NOW A- HI
ASSEMBLY MY NAME IS COURTNEY
BROWN IN CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
COMMUNITY COMPOSTING IN- OUR
SUPPORT OF THE APPLICATION FOR
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN EIGHTY
SEVEN AB. SB ONE SEVENTY B. B.
AGING AIRPORT COMPOSTING. OUR
OUR ALLIANCE HAS BEEN WORKING
WITH CAL RECYCLE SINCE OCTOBER
TWENTY TWENTY TO ADMINISTER
THEIR ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
COMMUNITY COMPOSTING PROGRAM
STATION I LIKE GRANT PROGRAM
WHICH RUNS THROUGH MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY THREE WE'RE WITNESSING
HOW INTERCULTURAL OPPORTUNITY
HAS CENTRAL BOTCHING EXPANDING
AND IMPROVING SMALL SCALE
COMPOSTING OPERATIONS WITH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND LABOUR IN
ORDER FOR THEM TO CONTRIBUTE TO
CALIFORNIA'S ORGANIC DIVERSION
TARGETS AND NOTHING REDUCTION
TARGETS AT A REGIONAL SCALE. IN
ADDITION TO OUR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
WE'VE ALSO DEVELOPED A
CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC COMMUNITY
COMPOSTERS TRAINING AND
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
INSTITUTE FOR LOCAL SELF
RELIANCE AND COMFORTING COUNCIL
THAT WATER COURT DECIDES AND
BASIC MARKET DEVELOPMENT
INCLUDING WORKING WITH METRICS
AND REPORTING LIABILITY
INSURANCE QUALITY ACCOMPLISH
QUALITY ASSURANCE SAFETY AND
OTHER KEY ELEMENTS NEED TO BE
IN PLACE TO ENSURE THESE
COMMUNITY APARTMENTS OPERATIONS
ARE ABLE TO SUSTAIN OPERATIONS
AFTER THE GRANT PERIOD AND
OFFERING. PLEASE PLEASE JOHNSON
HOW IS. ROBOTS THAT OUR
COMMUNITY. WE ARE WELCOME REYES
AT OUR TABLE WRONG. OF CAN OF
THE PROGRAM THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY. OF DIGNITY FUNDING. LINE
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE OF NOW
OPEN. A GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CRISTINA LOBBY
AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS JUST
CALLING TO THANK YOU FOR THE
SIGNIFICANT ADVANCEMENTS
INVESTMENTS AND WELFARE
PREVENTION. OF TO PHYSICALLY
SOME REPORTING LANGUAGE TO
IDENTIFY HOW THE FUNDS ARE
GOING OUT TO. LOCAL AGENCIES
WELL WE WERE ASKING FOR SOME
DIRECT ALLOCATION LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT WE
APPRECIATE. THE TRANSPARENCY
THAT WILL YIELD FROM THAT
LANGUAGE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
PRIORITIZATION OF SUPPORTING
THE CONTRACT COUNTIES AND HAND
CREWS AND- FOR THE WORKING
WITHIN THE- TO IDENTIFY FUTURE
CHANGES IN THE FORMULA TO FULLY
FUND THE SIGNIFICANT IMPORTANT
OPERATIONS. AND FINALLY- WE
APPRECIATE WELL IT'S NOT IN THE
BUDGET WE STILL CONTINUE TO
ADVOCATE FOR STAFFING IT CAL
FIRE AND LOOK FORWARD TO THE-
LABOR MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE THE
CAñADA FOR THE CHALLENGES ARE%
MEMBERS ARE FACING. DURING THE
TRIAL FIRE SEASON THAT IS A
YEAR ROUND EXHAUSTION AND NEVER
ENDING OF BATTLES THAT THEY
FACE ON THE FRONT LINES THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WELL I NINETY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHARLES BILL
GOT A SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
SUSTAINABLE CONSERVATION-
SPEAKINGINTO CORDS- OF S. B.
AB ONE THAT ONE FIFTY FIVE- THE
PROTECTION FIFTY ONE THE FIVE
HUNDRED NINETY THREE MILLION OR
MULTI BENEFIT A NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS. MAYBE THIS IS A
VALUABLE SOURCE OF RESOURCES
FOR CONDUCTING NEEDED
RESTORATION WORK IN RESPONSE TO
CLIMATE CHANGE THANK YOU. LINE
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. BACK IN YOUR CHAIR CHIANG
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS ARIANNA RECKON I REPRESENT
TOGETHER BAY AREA REGIONAL
COALITION OF SIXTY NINE NINE
PROFIT PUBLIC AGENCIES AND
INDIGENOUS TRIBES WORKING
TOGETHER FOR CLIMATE RESILIENT
MAN. I'M TRYING TO VOICE THEIR
SUPPORT FOR A BI SB ONE FIVE
FIVE EIGHT THE SP ONE SEVENTY
WE APPRECIATE THE FUNDING FOR
THE STATE CONFIDENCE SEVENTEEN
OF BILLS IN PARTICULAR THE BAY
PROGRAM WHICH IS CRITICAL THE
FUNNY MANY OF OUR MEMBERS
PROGRAMS AND PRIORITIES. WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE WORD UPON
APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN AB SB ONE FIVE
FIVE THE MOVE FOR ALLEGATIONS
THAT THE COST CONSERVANCY AND
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY
THREE AND TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR I WOULD LIKE TO
FEEL FUNDS ALLOCATED NOW RATHER
THAN IN FUTURE YEARS. AND I
LIKE TO ECHO A COMMENT FROM
PREVIOUS SPEAKER THAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE MORE FUNDING FOR
THIS CONSERVANCY FINALLY WE
ALSO SUPPORT THE SEQUENCE
STATUTORY EXEMPTION AND A. B.
S. B. ONE FIVE FIVE FOR
ENVIRONMENTALLY BENEFICIAL
RESTORATION PROJECTS REQUIRE
RESILIENCE ABOUT A RESCUE
PROTECTION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. CONSIDERATION AND FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP. MY FIVE YEAR
BLIGHTED NOW OPEN. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS PRODUCT
CARE DELIVERED ON BEHALF OF THE
CALTRAIN BOARD ACTION PLAN
BECOMING SUPPORT AB ONE SIXTY
KILL THE CREE OF THE COMMUNITY.
DIFFERENT STAFF AT ALL LEVELS
FOR ALL THE WORK IN CREATING
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CAITLYN
COLUSA ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
COULD KEEPER ALLIANCE WHICH
REPRESENTS LOCAL WATERKEEPER
ORGANIZATION ORGANIZATION THINK
WIDE. MY FIRST COMMENTS RELATE
TO THE MULTI YEAR WATER
RESILIENCE PACKAGE OUTLINED IN
AB ONE SEVENTY. AND WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THE GENERAL
PREPARATION OF SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR BOTH
DRINKING WATER AND WASTEWATER
PROJECTS WE URGE THAT EXPLICIT
FUNDING FOR WATER RECYCLING.
IDEALLY OF SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION AND FOR SOME WATER
CAPTURE PROJECTS FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION BEING INCLUDED IN
FUTURE BUDGET ALLOCATION ST
CREEK CALIFORNIA'S OVERALL
DROUGHT RESILIENCE. SECOND
REGARDING RESOURCES TRAIL- BILL
OUTLINED IN AB ONE FIFTY FIVE
WHICH SUPPORT AND THANK YOU FOR
THE EXTENSION OF THE SEPT WATER
SHUTOFF MORATORIUM AND ECHO THE
REQUEST BY LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
THAT THIS BE FURTHER EXPANDED.
TO CORRESPOND WITH THE ROLL OUT
OF DEBT RELIEF ASSISTANCE UNDER
THE LOCK PROGRAM. WE DECLARE
CONCERNING THE INCLUSION OF THE
SECRET COLLECTION AND ENCOURAGE
THAT THIS. PROVISION BE REMOVED
THANK YOU. LIKE TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON ALLOWED CHAU CARE A
LOT. WE LIKE TO THINK THAT BY
COMMITTEE INCLUDING THE CARE
PER REGION'S TO BRIDGE-
PROVIDERS REFUSED PAY NUMBER
NOT OPERATE DATE BURST THE- AP
PROGRAM DEFINITION TO INCLUDE
MICRO PROGRAM IN AB ONE SIXTY.
WE WANT THAT NONE THE BUDGET
BELT NOR EIGHT BE ONE ONE HAS
BREAKDOWN FOR THE USED TO FIND
ACTUALLY THE FEDERAL- DIVISION
GRANT ONE THAT CHILD CARE AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO RECEIVING
CLARITY ON THIS. POINT THANK
YOU. MY NINETY FOUR YEAR IF
THERE WILL. HELLO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WE ARE STILL ON WITH
THE ME WATER CALLING AT THE
PORT OF BUDGET BILL AB SLASH SB
ONE FIFTY FIVE ONE HUNDRED.
ARTICULAR FOR THE PROBLEM TO
WATER PROVISIONS. WHICH INCLUDE
A MORATORIUM WE ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY THIS ACCOUNT
ON THE CALIFORNIA COAST KEEPERS
WE GREATLY THANK YOU FOR
EXPLAINING THAT WATER SHUTOFF
MORATORIUM MEETING CRITICAL
WATER ACCESS. RELEASE FUNDS-
FROM THE WASTEWATER TREATMENT
PROGRAM ARE DISPERSED NO WE
WILL WASH PROGRAM CLOSELY IN
APPROACH INITIATION LEGISLATURE
FUNDING NOT THE PERSON WE
DISPERSED BY BEFORE THE END OF
THE YEAR WE ALSO AT THE
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL COMMENTS FOR
THE SPECIFIC SATISFIED FOR THE
ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION AND
IMPLEMENTATION AND LASTLY WOULD
SUPPORT THE HUNDRED MILLION
FOR. THE PEACE PROCESS SUPPORT
AGENCY WATER OVER THE NEXT
YEARS THANK YOU CHECKING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AFTER
LEADERSHIP AND PROTECTING THE
HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER BUT IT'S
CRITICAL. INVESTMENT PROTECTION.
LINE NINETY YEAR LINE NOW OPEN.
AFTERNOON MISTER MEMBERS THIS
IS BASICALLY OVER THE CALL LAW
ASTROLOGY AND SERVICES. I'M
GOING TO THANK BOTH THE OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES FOR OUR
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION TO
MAINTAIN A HEALTHY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES CAPACITY FOR
PHOSTRIA. ANSWER THANK THE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES FOR
ALLOCATING TEN POINT FOUR
MILLION TO TRANSITION
PROGRAMMING TO CONTINUE TO
SERVE THE US CURRENTLY
SUPPORTED AND AT THE R. T. P.
YOU LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT DEVELOP THE
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA AND
METHODOLOGY FOR DISTRIBUTION OF
THE FUNDING. THAT WHILE WE ARE
HAPPY TO SEE THESE ALLOCATIONS
FOR THE FIRST SIX MONTHS OF
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TWO
WE URGE THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO FUND THE FULL
COMPREHENSIVE AMOUNT REQUIRED
TO ENSURE STABILITY FOR FOSTER
YOUTH AS AS YOUR TPS OVER
SIXTEEN BAD TRANSITION THEIR
SERVICES. THROUGH FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY THREE
THANK YOU. LINE FIFTY TWO YEAR
IS NOW. GOOD AFTERNOON UNDER
OWN BEHALF OF THE CANNABIS
EQUITY COUNSEL IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB AT THE ONE SIXTY
SIX WE THANK THE LEGISLATURE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THEIR
DEDICATION TO EMBARK ON
CANNABIS EQUITY POLICIES.
SPECIFICALLY WE ARE PLEASED TO
SEE A MINIMUM 50% OWNERSHIP
REQUIREMENTS QUALIFY AS AN
EQUITY APPLICANT OR LICENSEE
INTERN JURISDICTION WHICH WE
BELIEVE IS KEY TO SUPPORTING
EQUITY ENTREPRENEURS AS THEY
WORK TOWARDS SUCCESS IN THIS
INDUSTRY. THANK YOU. LIKE WHAT
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIRED MEMBERS ANY FRANCO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA. WE
WERE DISCONNECTED WHEN ONE OH
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIR NUMBERS MY CAROL WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW POVERTY
WE WANT TO START BY JUST
THANKING THE COMMITTEE AND ALL
THE STAFF FOR. THE INCREDIBLE
HARD WORK THAT EVERYONE IS PUT
IN DURING THIS REMARKABLE
BUDGET YEAR. TODAY'S HEARING WE
ARE WE WANT TO GET A CALL UP
THE FOLLOWING BILLS FOR
SUPPORT. SB ONE SIXTY TWO WHICH
INCLUDE THE FUNDING FOR THE
TRANSCRIPT REIMBURSEMENT FUNDS.
SB ONE SEVENTY WHICH INCLUDES
FUNDING FOR AFGHAN REFUGEES
REFUGEES BUT WE DO HOPE IT WILL
SEE SOME FUNDING NEXT YEAR FOR
THE EXISTING REFUGEES COULD NOT
YET HAD FUNDING APPROPRIATED-
SB ONE SEVENTY CHIU HUMAN
SERVICES LANGUAGE. TO INCREASE
POWER CAN INCOME DISREGARDS FOR
APPLICANTS. SB ONE SEVENTY SIX
WHICH LIMITS HAVE TO BE
COLLECTIONS FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES. SB ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
WHICH REPEAL SEVENTEEN CRIMINAL
FEES. AND BARS COLLECTION OF
THE STREET AFTER DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST. IT ALSO. I
FUNDING FOR QUARTER TO MAKE
SURE THAT COIN AND- WALKED
TENURE. GET A- SO THEY CAN UP A
BAD THIS IF ONE HAPPENS TO THEM
AND THOSE ACTIONS THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR ALL YOUR WORK TO
SHARE. LINE ONE OH THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR KING AND MEMBERS TYRONE
GET ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PRACTICES
ENGINE WITH AN ABF THE ONE
SEVENTY WORKERS SHOULD HAVE THE
ALLOCATION TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
TO SUPPORT HIGH SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC
PROGRAMS NUMBER SIXTEEN BAD
BETTER ANALYTICAL FRAN
RECEIVING FEDERAL FUNDING INTO
INSPECT THEM IN TRANSITIONING
THEIR PROGRAMS YOUR CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE FEDERAL FUNDING
ALTHOUGHIT ACKNOWLEDGED THAT
THE NEED WITHIN THAT AREA. IS
THE- GREATER IT AND ABOUT THE
FINANCING DOES NOT FULLY
ADDRESS THE LOCK AND FEDERAL
FUNDING WE SUPPORT THE
AUTHORIZING LANGUAGE FOR
FEDERAL FINANCING FOR ABOUT HOW
YOUR DH YEAH WE ALSO SUPPORT OF
EMPATHETIC SIDE FOR SMALL
COUNTIES WITHIN THE COMMUNITY
CARE EXPANSION PROGRAM UNDER.
EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY TWO THANK
YOU. MY NINETY YEAR LINE NOW
OPEN. JERRY MEMBERS- NINE SPINA
NO THAT'S FINE ON BEHALF OF THE
FAN EXPLICATION OF COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES CALLING ON AB ONE
SIXTY NINE THE HIGHER EDUCATION
TRAILER BILL WE HAVE FOUND
LETTER TO THE COMMITTEE BUT
WANTED TO STRESS THAT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING FUNDING SOON
FOR THE HIGHER EDUCATION
CAPACITY EXPANSION GRANT
PROGRAM WHICH IS NOT CURRENTLY
HAPPENING IN THE BILL. THANK
YOU. MY NINETY TWO YEAR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ELECTED TO
HIGH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
CALLING IN SUPPORT AND EIGHTY
SB ONE SEVENTY SPECIFICALLY
THAT UPDATE TO THE PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE AND PACIFIC AT A
HUNDRED MILLION ARM. I HAVE
SIGNED FOR COKE WOULD RELIEF
FOR INDEPENDENT SPECIAL
DISTRICTS WE HAVE ONE TO REALLY
CHANGE AND APPRECIATE AND THE
FACT DEPARTMENTS AND
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET STAFFERS ARE
EITHER COOPERATION AND HARD
WORKING WORKING. WITH ACTED
ABOUT THE PROGRAM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MY NINETY THREE YEAR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. MR SURE
MEMBERS BRADY BORDERING WITH
FUEL CELL ENERGY ANDWANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
WORK ON THE EXTENSION OF THE
CHILLS ON THAT ENERGY METERING
PROGRAM FOR TWO YEARS- IN
CALLING I WAS IN SUPPORT OF SB
ONE FIFTY FIVE WHICH IS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL TO ADDING
CAPACITY TO THE GRID NEXT
COUPLE YEARS. I JUST CONTINUE
TO FACE DEMAND AND SUPPLY
CHALLENGES WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
AGAIN AND STEPS IN THE FUTURE
ON THIS PROGRAM. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ONE ONE TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI IT SHERRIN
MEMBERS ANY FRANCO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION I WANNA MAKE SURE
I'M COMING THROUGH OKAY. PLEASE
GO CAN YOU HEAR ME ALRIGHT YOUR
PLEASE PLEASE GO. PLEASE SPEAK
OKAY OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH I
JUST WANTED TO QUICKLY CALL IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT EIGHTY ONE
SIXTY SIX OF THE CANNABIS
EQUITY PROVISIONS PARTICULARLY
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
A DRAFTING THE TECHNICAL ISSUE.
AROUND PROVISIONAL LICENSURE
ALLOTMENT FOR CANNABIS EQUITY
MAKING SURE THAT ALL EQUITY
LIKE IF YOU CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THAT ALSO REALLY WANT TO
APPLAUD THE COMMITMENT TO A
STATEWIDE EQUITY DEFINITION FOR
PURPOSES ISSUE A PRISON
DEFERRAL. THIS IS AN ISSUE THE
SEATTLE I'VE BEEN COMMITTED YOU
FOR YEARS WE REALLY WANT TO GET
THAT APPLIED TH LEGISLATURE
FOR THE COMMITTEE TO THAT- AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUED
COOPERATION WITH THE DEPARTMENT
ON UP FOR THE REFINING WHAT
THAT DEFINITION LOOKS LIKE. TO
ENSURE WE ARE IMPACTING THE
MOST AT THE MOST. NEEDED
POPULATIONS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ONE FOR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN BRIDGE OKAY
ON BEHALF ARE AREN'T SERVICES
AND RETHINK WASTE IN SUPPORT OF
THE ONE HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS FROM G. G. R. S. FOR SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND LOCAL
pTHE FUNDING FROM THE CIRCULAR
ECONOMY PACKAGE. FOR SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE RELATED
INFRASTRUCTURE AND COMPOSTING
PROJECTS THANK YOU. WELL I
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE
MEMBERS AND WHATNOT YOU WITH
CLIMATE CENTER HERE IT'S PART
OF VARIOUS ITEMS IN BOTH ABA SB
ONE SEVENTY AND BRIDGES TRAILER
BILL. FIFTY FIVE INCLUDING THIS
YEAR'S TEN MILLION DOLLAR
COVERAGE OF YOUR FOR ADAPTATION
RESUMES HUNTING GROUNDS AND
FUTURE ALLOCATIONS IN OUT YEARS
FOR EXTREME HEAT THANK YOU
BASED MOTIONS AND COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE CENTERS. WE HELP AND
FUTURE YEARS THERE WILL ALSO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
COMMUNITY AND IT WAS ON FINING
FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
CRITICAL TO ENSURING THE
STRATEGIC PLAN A QUICK
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCES. I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR
AND STAFF. FOR ALL THEIR HARD
WORK ON THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
THANK YOU. ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS FAMILY AGAINST
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE SUPPORT IN AB SB
ONE FIFTY SEVEN TO EXPAND THE
ASSIGNMENT MAXIMUM TEST AT THE
TWO TEACHERS FROM THIRTY TO
SIXTY DAYS. THE PROVISIONS TO
PROVIDE REMOTE LEARNING TO
QUARANTINE STUDENTS AND FUNDING
TO DO SO FROM THE FIRST DAY OF
THE SALUTE ONE GENE WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION
AND LEGISLATORS EFFORTS IN
RECENT BUDGET TO PRIORITIZE
EDUCATOR RETENTION AND TRAINING
PROJECTS DREAM IMPORTANT DURING
THE ONGOING SCHOOL EMPLOYEE
SHORTAGE. WITH IMPORTANT CANYON
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATIVE AND LEGISLATIVE
STAFF D. D. E. AND F. B. THAT
REGARDING IMPLEMENTATION OF
THESE PROVISIONS DURING TO
ENSURE WE STAFF AS WE PROGRESS
OUT OF THE PANDEMIC. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PARTNERSHIP
ON THIS EFFORT AND AGAIN WE
SUPPORT- THESE AND THEN. WHEN
WE DON'T HAVE YOUR MIND NOW
OPEN. THANK YOU TERM MEMBERS
APPOINTED BY WITH YOUR FOR IN A
ONE TO THANK THE STAFF WE ARE
ON THE PROJECT ALSO EXPRESSED
BROWN FOR. HIS COMMENTS THE
CALL TO DISCUSS AROUND IF
YOU'LL COME ENERGY MEETING. WE
APPRECIATE WHY THANK ALL OF YOU
FOR YOUR RECOGNIZED. OF IN
THREE. OF TOTAL. AND THE PRO.
OF OG ON THE OR WITH THE MORE
ON THE STREET. AND REALLY. ALL
YOUR HELP ON THAT. WE ALSO BUT
WE REMAIN CONCERNED WITH OTHER
ASPECTS OF THE BUDGET TRAILER
BILL PARTICULARLY AS IT RELATES
TO FUNDING LONG TERM AGREEMENT
SPECIFICALLY. AND SB ONE
SEVENTY TO FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN SECTION TEN AN
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN SECTION
ELEVEN. WE ENCOURAGE MORE GUARD
ROLLED AROUND THAT FUNDING IF
NOT SO COMPLETELY IN THE NATION
OF THE BILL'S PROVISIONS. AND
WE ALSO WOULD ENCOURAGE- BUT
LIMITING AS WELL THIS YEAR
PROTECTION AS MENTIONED BY.
OTHERS BEFORE ME THANK YOU. ONE
SEVENTY PIC LATEST OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MARK FENSTER
ON THE BECOME MAN STEWARDSHIP
THAT CALIFORNIA STATE RESOURCE
CON DISTRICT- IN SUPPORT OF SB
ONE FIFTH FIVE ENTERED. SECTION
THREE GREAT QUICK- WE TRY TO
STAY OUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
INTERPRETATION FOR THE HARD
WORK BY THE ADMINISTRATION OF
THE LEGISLATURE TO FIND
WORKABLE LANGUAGE- TO MAINTAIN
MISTER ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTIONS ALSO DANCING THIS
NEW CRITICAL EFFICIENCY TO OUR
REGULATORY CRAFTED SEATS.
RESTORATION PRACTITIONERS HAVE
BEEN ASKING FOR THIS TRANSPORT
TRANSFORMATIONAL POLICY CHANGES
TO ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE
BIODIVERSITY LOSS AND SPECIES
PROTECTION AND THIS PROPOSAL.
WILL HELP ANSWER THAT REQUEST
THANK YOU SO MUCH. LATE NINE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SEAT CRUISE WITH
CRUISE STRATEGIES ON THE APP
SAN JOSE MAYOR SAM LICCARDO IN
SUPPORT OF THE FUEL CELL NET
ENERGY METERING EXTENSION
INCLUDING AB ONE FIFTY FIVE AND
FIFTY ONE FIFTY FIVE. THANK YOU
SEVEN MOBILE AND SAID THREE FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE THANK YOU. ONE EIGHTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
HELLO CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JENNIFER MALEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THAT
HIGHLAND EFFORTS- BY
LEGISLATORS COMMITTEE STAFF AND
NGO OUT FROM THE BUDGET CLEANUP
BILLS RECENTLY RELEASED. I
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION JUST A COUPLE
ITEMS- IN HOME SUPPORT SERVICES
CAREER PATHWAYS TRAINING- IT
WILL PROVIDE PAY TRAINING WITH
INCENTIVES TO CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CAREER
ADVANCEMENT IN THE HOME CARE
AND HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY TO
REALLY APPRECIATE WORK ON THAT.
I ALSO WANTED TO MENTION THE
INCREDIBLE INVESTMENT AND HIGH
ROAD TRAINING OPPORTUNITY
THROUGH THE COMMUNITY ECONOMIC
RESILIENCE I'M- IN EIGHTY S. B.
ONE EIGHTY SB ONE SIXTY TWO.
RESHAPED WORK THE LEGISLATURE
IS DONE TO ENSURE THAT THE
PROGRAMSRECEIVING GRANT
FUNDING ARE SUPPORTING THE
MISSION OF CREATING HIGH
QUALITY JOBS. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THAT UNION JOBS
PROVIDE QUALITY JOBS WITH
LIVABLE WAGES AND IS AN
IMPORTANT PART OF ADJUSTING
EQUITY IN THE WORKFORCE. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND REVIEWING
FUTURE REPORTS ON GRANT
AWARDEES ANALYZING THE NUMBER
OF SIGNATORY EMPLOYERS.
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS AND THE
NUMBER OF UNION JOB SEARCHES
NONUNION SHOPS THAT PARTICIPATE
IN THE PROGRAM. AS WE TRY TO
BUILD A QUALITY IN EQUITY
WORKFORCE THANK YOU AGAIN AND
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
ONE ONE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THE
HEAT NORTH THE ROAD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
ARE CARE C. STRONGLY SUPPORTS
THE CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION IN
AB FLASHSB ONE FIFTY FIVE FOR
FORCED HEALTH FUNDING AND
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT TO
WILDFIRE PREVENTION ACTIVITIES
HOWEVER WE'D LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT PROVISIONS IN THE PROPOSED
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX EIGHTY. COULD
MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT TO GET
THE FUNDS ON THE GROUND IN FIRE
PRONE COMMUNITIES DUE TO AN
ALREADY SHORT SUPPLY OF LABOR
TO PERFORM VITAL FOREST HEALTH
AND RESILIENCE WORK WE URGE YOU
TO FIND A SOLUTION AB SIXTY
NEED TO ENSURE THAT THESE FUNDS
CAN BE UTILIZED TO THEIR
GREATEST BENEFIT IN THE
COMMUNITIES THE GREATEST RISK.
ARE HERE SHE ALSO STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE APPLICATION IN AB
S. B. ONE SEVENTY TWO KARAKUL
FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF WASTE
PRODUCTION AND MANAGEMENT
PROGRAMS PARTICULARLY BE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY P. ORGANICS REGULATIONS.
THANK YOU. ONE ONE SIXTEEN YEAR
IS NOW A- GOOD AFTERNOON LADIES
PHANTASM BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA CALLING TO EXPRESS
DEEP APPRECIATION FOR
ALLOCATION. FOR ONGOING FUNDING
FOR A TRANSCRIPT RATE INCREASE
FOR COURT REPORTERS AS WELL AS
AN ONGOING ALLOCATION FOR THE
HIRING OF OFFICIAL COURT
REPORTERS BY COURT ROUTE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- THE
TRANSCRIPT RATE INCREASE IS AN
INCREASE WE HAVE THOUGHT.
THIRTY ONE YEARS AND ARE SO
VERY APPRECIATIVE THAT THIS IS
THE YEAR THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
ALLOCATED WE ALSO ARE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE ONGOING
FUNDING FOR THE HIRING OF COURT
REPORTERS AS THIS WILL BETTER
ENSURE EQUAL ACCESS TO JUSTICE
AS WELL THE ONE TIME
ALLOCATION. FOR THE TRANSCRIPT
REIMBURSEMENT FUND AND WE'RE
ALSO VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
BOX FELL OF ALLOCATION TO THE
COURT TO ADDRESS THE
ELIMINATION. OF CRIMINAL FEES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE ONE
DAY YEAR IS DOUBLE. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ALEX GRAVES
WITH THE ASSOCIATION
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES JUST WANTED TO
REGISTER SUPPORT FOR A BI S. B.
ONE SIX NINE. I WHICH AMONG
OTHER THINGS- ADDRESSES- AT THE
CAL GRANT INCREASED FOR BOTH
OUR NEW AND RENEWAL RECIPIENTS
AND ALSO- ELIMINATES THE
SELECTIVE SERVICE REQUIREMENTS
FOR STATE AID PROGRAMS- BRING
US INTO ALIGNMENT WITH CHANGES
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL THANK YOU.
ONE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON ANY MARKET
WITH LIMB ENERGY WITH THE PARK
A FUEL CELL PHONE TECHNICIAN
CONTAINED IN AB F. ONE FIFTY
FIVE THE BOOK IS A HIGHLY
RESILIENT CLEAN TECHNOLOGY
AVAILABLE TO CALIFORNIANS
DURING THAT TIME A CRITICAL
NEED. THANK YOU. ONE ONE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON REBEKAH MARKET
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AFTER THE ONE SEVENTY THREE THE
FIRST PROVISION OF COMMON SENSE
TO PROTECT YOU YOUR STAFF AND
THE PUBLIC THE DATA SHARING
PROVISION WILL ALSO PLAY A
CRUCIAL ROLE IN THE ANALYSIS
ULTIMATELY IS TO PREVENT THE
SENSELESS LOSS OF LIFE DUE TO
GUN VIOLENCE. ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FARMLAND TRUST CARBON
CYCLE ONCE IN THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE AN AD NETWORK REGARDING
SB ONE SEVENTY I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
LARGE OVERALL INVESTMENT IN
HEALTHY SOIL FUNDING FOR SWEEP
AND THE CONSERVATION PLANNING
GRANT PROGRAM AND THE FUNDING
FOR. AND PRIORITIZATION OF AMP
WE ARE DISAPPOINTED THAT THE
FINAL BUDGET COULD NOT FIND
CRITICAL AGRICULTURAL
PROTECTION THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA FARMLAND CONSERVANCY
PROGRAM ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT WAYS TO MAXIMIZE
AGRICULTURE'S ABILITY TO HELP
FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE BY
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND REMOVING CARBON
FROM THE ATMOSPHERE TO THE
COURT THE PERMANENT
CONSERVATION. OF ATLANTA THANK
YOU. ONE ONE OH SIX YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
HAVE A LOCK ON OF THE CAN ALLOW
THE FAMILY. THANK YOU TO MISTER
CHAIR ASSEMBLY õBER
MEMBERS AND THEIR STAFF ARE
WORKING AND FINDING A FARM TO
COMMUNITY FOOD HUB PROGRAMS
BEGINNING FARMER TRAINING
PROGRAM AND ALSO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO FURTHER. FINDING
DIRECT RELIEF AND
INFRASTRUCTURE SUPPORT FOR
SMALL FARMERS IMPACTED BY THE
DROUGHT SECOND ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTER FOR FOOD SAFETY WE WISH
WE WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOW
EMBERS AND BACK AGAIN FOR
FINDING A HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM
THE POLLINATOR HABITAT
PROGRAMS. AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR CONSERVATION
MANAGEMENT PLANS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO ENSURING. PLANS
INCLUDE AND SUPPORT ORGANIC
TRANSITION PLAN. THANK YOU
AGAIN MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
WHY WHY TWENTY YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. OKAY THE NUMBER OF
COLOSSAL CLEAN WATER ACTION AND
WATER FOUNDATION CALLING FOR
THE BUDGET TRAILER BILL AB SB
ONE FIFTY FIVE A ONE SEVENTY I
WITH THE POINT THANK YOU FOR
THE WATER SHUT OFF MORE
CONDESCENSION CONTROL MAINTAIN
CRITICAL ARE ACTIVE FALL
REALLY. FUNCTIONAL WATER
WASTEWATER LEADERS PAYMENT
PROGRAM ARE DISPERSED AND- WILL
CONTINUE TO WATCH THE PROGRAM
CLOSELY AS AN APPROACH A
NEGOTIATION THE LEGISLATURE AT
THE FUNDING IS NOT SUFFICIENTLY
DISTRICTS APART BUT AND BE
HERE. SECOND OFFICE FOR ABOUT
HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION PERSON
ONE CONDITION AND A HUNDRED
MILLION TO ATTRACT PEOPLE FROM
DRINKING WATER BOB THANK YOU
CHECK. BURDENS DR LEADERSHIP
AND PROTECTING HUMAN RIGHTS
WATER I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ECHO
COMMENTS MADE BY LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL THE WATER CENTER AND
OTHERS. ARE KIND OF CONNECTION
THANK YOU. I MY NINETY SEVEN
YEAR LINE IS NOW OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN ARE PREMEDICAL
CHARTERS CENTER. THANK YOU FOR
SLUGGING IT OUT IT LOOKS LET
ALONE UP THERE THE DIAL-
SUBSTANTIVELY WE WOULD- URGE
YOU TO AND THE PROBATE THAT THE
SENATE ADDED IN THAT MISSION
FROM THE VERSION OF- SB ONE
SIXTY SEVEN IN FRONT OF YOU
THAT WOULD PROTECT NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER
SCHOOLS. WERE ALSO CONCERNED
ABOUT A PROVISION IN SB ONE
SIXTY SEVEN THAT WOULD ADD
ADDITIONAL SYNCHRONOUS
INSTRUCTION BURDENS TO LONG
TERM INDEPENDENT STUDY STUDENTS
AND THEIR FAMILIES. MANY OF THE
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES LIKELY
INDEPENDENT ASPECT OF
INDEPENDENT STUDY IN OUR
SUCCESSFUL WITHOUT SYNCHRONOUS
ONLINE INSTRUCTION AND DON'T
WANT THE ADDITIONAL BURDEN. WE
ASK THESE ADDITIONAL BURDENS BE
DELETED FROM THE BILL FINALLY
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT REMOVING
LONGSTANDING EMERGENCY
ATTENDANCE AND FUNDING PROJECT
PROJECT I PROTECTIONS FROM THE
BILL CONTRARY TO WHAT YOU'VE
HEARD IN TESTIMONY SB ONE SIXTY
SEVEN ACTUALLY DOES DELETE
THESE LONG STANDING COULD CHIP
PROTECTIONS. WHICH FOR MANY
DECADES HAVE SPECIFICALLY
INCLUDED PROTECTIONS FOR SCHOOL
FUNDING IN CASE OF PANDEMICS WE
SUGGEST DELETING THESE NEW
PROHIBITIONS ON THE BILL AND
ALLOWING THESE LONG STANDING.
PROTECTIONS TO CONTINUE AS THEY
HAVE. OVER THIRTY YEARS THANK
YOU. WELL I WANT TO SIX JULY IS
THAT WHAT. YEAH CHAIR I MONEY I
RIGHT TO AMERICA WONDERFUL.
ALONG ASSOCIATION APPRECIATE
APPRECIATE ONGOING ATTENTION TO
CLEAN THE AIR FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS SHOWN IN THIS
BUDGET PROCESS I WE APPRECIATE
THE INCLUSION OF SEVERAL KEY
CLEAN AIR PROVISIONS IN A. B.
S. B. ONE SEVENTEEN INCLUDING
FIRST FUNDING FOR. SB SIX
SEVENTEEN IMPLEMENTATION
PROGRAMS AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT SECOND THIRTY
MILLION- FOR THEIR INFORMATION
SMALL OFF ROAD. ENGINES AND-
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT- IMPORTING AND
COMPLIMENTS TO ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX AND THEN
LAST WEEK FIVE MILLION THE
WOODSTOVE- REPLACEMENT THANK
YOU AGAIN- FOR THE STRONG.
FOCUS ON CLEAN AIR THANK. BY
ONE ONE TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE
OF NOW OPEN HEY GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIR ENJOYMENT HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE ENERGY AT IN THE
COURT. SB IN AB ONE FIFTY FIVE
AND ONE SEVENTY SIX I THINK WE
THE INVESTMENT FOR SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE IMPLEMENTATION
ENERGIYA. GLOBAL LEADER IN
CONVERTING ORGANIC WASTE
STREAMS TO RENEWABLE ENERGY AND
WE BELIEVE THESE INVESTMENTS
WILL HELP THAT SUCCESSFULLY
MEET THE. THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
RECYCLING TARGET THANK YOU.
LINE ONE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON LINDA WAY
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WANTED TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT THIRTY TWO ADDITIONAL
BILLS ONE FIFTY FIVE WHICH
EXTENDS WATER SHUTOFF
MORATORIUM AND WOULD ENCOURAGE
A SIMILAR EXTENSION FOR RENTAL
ASSISTANCE AND ONE SEVENTY ONE
WHICH PROVIDES AN EVALUATION OF
WHETHER THE STATE HAS A NET
HOUSING SUPPORT SERVICE
PROVIDERS PER TEACHER MEDICARE
BENEFIT. AND A ONE YEAR
EXTENSION OF THE TIME AND
DISTANCE THAT EXPERIMENTAL
MEDICARE PLAN ENROLLEES THANK
YOU. WELL ONE TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. CHAIRED
MEMBERS DANIEL SANCHEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CHEAP PROBATION
OFFICERS WE APPRECIATE THE
FUNDING INCLUDED IN S. B. AB
ONE SEVENTY PER BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES IN S. T. R. T.
P.'S. DEFINING AND IMPORTANT TO
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER
YOUTH AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION ON ADDITIONAL
FUNDING THAT MAY BE NEEDED IN
THIS REGARD TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE CRITICAL INVESTMENTS TO
SUPPORT FOSTER YOUTH IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. ONE
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI
THIS IS LAURA FONSECA ON BEHALF
OF THE RESOURCE RECOVERY
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
ALLOCATIONS FOR WITH THE
VERSION AND FIVE INFRASTRUCTURE
AND SB. THIRTEEN THREE
IMPLEMENTATION BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THANK YOU. BEFORE
WE OPEN LIKE ONE THIRTY ONE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE
ONE THIRTY ONE LINE IS NOW OPEN-
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS. WELCOME
HAPPY HELPER TO OUR ALLIANCE.
WITH OUR SUPPORT A. B. SB ONE
SEVENTY IN PARTICULAR THE
FUNDING FOR THE CALGARY TALKING
CERGY- THESE INVESTMENTS WILL
HAVE. OR BE CRITICAL CONNECTION
TO BE- VERTICAL AND FIGHTING
WILDFIRES THAT ARE. ONLY GOING
ON. IN THE- FUEL REDUCTION
ABOUT STATION MANAGEMENT
PROJECT SO. WE CREATE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE ONE
TWENTY TWO YEAR LINE IS NOW
OPEN- GOOD AFTERNOON CHRIS NOW
ON BEHALF OF SB FIVE G. GEO
SPATIAL IN SUPPORT OF AB S. B.
ONE SEVENTY WITH RESPECT TO THE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
PROPOSED TO BE INVESTED FOR THE
DEPLOYMENT. OF REMOTE SENSING
TECHNOLOGIES AS AN INTRAPARTY
CALIFORNIA'S WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AND FORCE RESILIENCY
STRATEGY THANK YOU. LINE
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HI ARE. YOU CALLING ON
BEHALF WITHOUT WITH THE
AUTHORITY WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR INCLUDING ME
ARE CRITICALLY NEEDED FUNDING
FOR THE STOCK MARKET PART OF
THE PACKAGE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ONE ONE AWAIT YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HI MY ARE GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRPERSON AND MEMBERS. IT'S
HARD NOT TO COMMENT THAT'S
PROVISIONAL FUNDING OVER
EXACTLY FUNDING FOR WATER
SPORTS AND THIS IS DEFINITELY
IN CALIFORNIA- LITTLE ROCK ONE-
ACCEPTABLE I AGREE WITH JAMES
GALLAGHER ANDRIGHT THANK YOU
MA'AM- THE CARD IS THE- AS FOR
THE- PUBLIC OF BUT THE BUDGET
YOU TO BE ON TOP OF THE BUDGET.
HI THERE ARE YOU KNOW WE NEED A
BEARD WE DIRECT THAT THE WATERS
ARE. INSURANCE AND FARMERS HAVE-
I QUIT WATER IS NOT FAR FROM
NEWS AND ALL THE- ARE THAT THEY
CREATE THE TIME AND I I'M
CALLING FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR THAT THANK. AND ONCE AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN BEFORE
YOU'LL UP ONE A LOT. LIKE TO
HAVE A MAKE A PUBLIC YOU MADE
ONE AT THE DEALER AT THIS.
MIGHT WANT ELEVEN YOU'LL IS
OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSION
WHITE ON BEHALF OF WHICH-
LICENSE FORCES SOCIAL. AND THE
FOURTH ADRIFT. ALSO IN SOME OF
THE CONTINUES A- FOR AWHILE. OF
WE BELIEVE THAT. AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE SOCIAL OF PURSE
LEARNING IN SCHOOL SERVICES A
PLUS- WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE
STAFF'S ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS WITH THE DEFINITION OF
SYNCHRONOUS. WELL WE DO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS AT THE TECHNICAL
LANGUAGE THAT WE WERE SEEKING
TO ALLOW FOR ANY CREDENTIAL
TEACHER- WAS NOT INCLUDED. AND
SO WE- WE WILL CONTINUE AB WAS
CONCERNED AND TRYING RIPPLES
OUT THROUGH EITHER- THE
CALIFORNIA PRIMARY EDUCATION OR
THROUGH VARIOUS OTHER MEANS. IN
THE FUTURE. THANK YOU. ONE
FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GREETINGS TO THE ASSEMBLY AND
EVERYBODY MY NAME IS
OPPORTUNITY NOT ALL AND I WANT
TO MAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT ON AB.
ONE SIXTY SIX- AGAIN MY NAME IS
APPETITE GONNA ON THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE SOCIAL EQUITY
OWNERS AND WORKERS ASSOCIATION
AND I WANTED TO SAY- THAT WE
APPRECIATE- THE GESTURE AND THE
FIRST STEP IN THE DIRECTION OF
PRIORITIZING SOCIAL EQUITY IN.
YOUR CAR OPEN WE STILL WANT TO
URGE THE ASSEMBLY IN AUGUST OF
THE LEGISLATURE. TO COME UP
WITH THE OTHER STATE WIDE
DEFINITION FOR SOCIAL EQUITY AS
IT PERTAINS TO. THE ENTIRE
STATE WE NEED A UNIFIED
DEFINITION SO THAT STATE A CITY
BY STATE IN THE WORLD ARE NOT
CHANGED AND WE DON'T DUPLICATE
THE TOOK PLACE IN LOS ANGELES
FOR THAT MATTER INCH AND THAT.
MANY OF THE SURVIVORS OF THE
WAR ON DRUGS OR NOT PRIORITIZE
AND ACTUALLY WHAT ABLE TO GET
THE LICENSE IN THE PROCESS SO.
THANK YOU FOR THE LANGUAGE
CHANGE IN THE WORLD. LET'S MAKE
SURE THAT WE PRIORITIZE THE
STATE WIDE SOCIAL EQUITY
DEFINITIONS OF THE RESOURCE IS
GO TO THE- THE POPULAR
SURVIVORS OF THE WAR ON DRUGS.
THANK YOU HAVE A BEAUTIFUL DAY.
JERRY STILLER ELSE ON THE
PUBLIC COME. GREAT THANK YOU
OPERATOR- SEE MORE COME IN THE-
I ROOM WAS A SOMEONE ARE YOU
RISING TO MAKE COUPLE HEARING
LO. THANKS VERY MUCH IF I CAN'T
JUST MAKE A QUICK COMMENT- MY
NAME IS WILL ABRAMS OF A
WILDFIRE SURVIVOR IN SUPPORT OF
SB ONE FIFTY FIVE. AND WHILE I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE- MID TERM
AND LONG TERMBENEFITS OF THIS
LEGISLATION I JUST WANT TO
REMIND THE COMMITTEE. THAT
THEIR WILDFIRE SURVIVORS RIGHT
NOW SUFFERING IN TRAILERS
TRYING TO PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE
AND RELIANCE ON THE FIRE VICTIM
TRUST WHICH HAS BEEN
UNDERMINED. BY P. JEANNIE
INVESTORS AND ATTORNEYS TO
ENSURE THAT WERE HOLDING STOCK.
WHILE OTHER INVESTORS BENEFIT
FROM OUR STOCK POSITION I WOULD
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO ENGAGE IN
THESE ISSUES AND ENCOURAGE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO LOOK INTO
THE MATTER. OF HOW THE TRUST
WAS FORMED THIS CANNOT BE
PRECEDENT FOR HOW VICTIMS ARE
GONNA BE TREATED IN THE FUTURE.
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S FOCUS ON THESE ISSUES
GOING FORWARD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU OPERATOR ANYMORE
PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE. NO SORRY
SO NO ONE ELSE WANTED TO MAKE A
PUBLIC COMMENT. THANK YOU THEN
WITH THAT WE ARE DIRT.